[SPEAKER_02]: Hello, I am Eska.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I am playing as William.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello, I am Calder.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello, I am Felix.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I am Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, we begin.
[SPEAKER_01]: The year is 756.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is Tear 00 or Tear 100, which is the very last day of the autumn season of Tear.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it is Harvest Fest, which is a festival of plenty and abundance and celebrating all of the food stuffs that have been harvested over the month.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, you know, at the period of time when everyone's stores are full and there's essentially extra food available,
[SPEAKER_01]: People celebrate this holiday by coming to market, selling off the abundance, the extra that they don't need and making a bit of money out of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there is always a lot of food related celebrations, people head to the market and also sort of like food fairs and that type of thing as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are starting in an area between the stacks and the core.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a square called Oblong Square.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is a rectangular square in the core that leads up against the stacks, so it's right at the border between the core and the stacks and is always very heavily populated with a lot of traffic.
[SPEAKER_01]: People that come past
[SPEAKER_01]: on a regular day it's relatively busy, but today more so than ever it is particularly busy as Harvestfest is on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let me just bring everyone to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: The square is, yeah, rammed with people.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are market stalls down the sides.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can obviously see in the background the stacks, the chimney around which these piles of houses that people live in have slowly built up over the evolution of the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: And here is this sort of area between the slightly better off
[SPEAKER_01]: core area where a lot of the guild employees work tenements blocks owned by the guilds are here and people live and work within the core for the big industrial projects of the city and then bordering on the stacks where it is a little poorer and generally the sort of more manual laborers and poor elements of the city live in the stacks but it's by no means a sort of
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, if you live in the stacks, you're poor.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you live in the core, you're better off.
[SPEAKER_01]: It tends to be a lot more diverse than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But nonetheless, here in Oblong Square, we find ourselves outside a particular inn called the Plum and Bob, which is an inn on this square that
[SPEAKER_01]: is one of many inns on this particular square.
[SPEAKER_01]: But this is a haunt of one of our PCs on a regular basis, and I will ask Asuka to introduce their character, what we would see, what you would be doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not necessarily playing here tonight, but you are just enjoying the festivities either at the Plumber Bob or in the square itself.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, wait, wait, actually...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to stop you because before you say too much about your character, just give us what people would see initially.
[SPEAKER_01]: So don't go too much in depth into actually like things that you wouldn't know without actually speaking to you, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm a bard with my loot.
[SPEAKER_02]: I like to mingle with people, have fun and I like to drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: And are you in the Plum and Bob drinking right now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I would be in the plumber bar and speaking to some locals and having a nice drink.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know the clientele, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we sort of zoom in on this scene and just give us a broad overview of what you look like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, what are you wearing?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your kind of general vibe, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I am wearing general clothes that makes me blend in with the locals.
[SPEAKER_02]: And a little bit messy hair, a little bit messy face, but not like a homeless person messy, but just general worn out civilian messy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Civilian message So you are sitting in in the Yeah, you're sitting in the plumber Bob there's a few locals here that you know and you also know the Bartender here who is called hall Mott.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is well known to anyone who frequents the plumber Bob.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a big guy he's
[SPEAKER_01]: tending drinks are very kind of stressed out as everything is very busy and you think he should probably be happy but he's a little bit just pissed off for the stress of it despite the fact that the place is buzzing and has way more people than it would normally have and he throws you over a slide you across a drink and he says ask are you going to be playing tonight?
[SPEAKER_02]: boss if that's if that's what you want me to do you know my rates and you know you know tonight it's a big night so yeah I am more than willing to
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah, I mean, I can clear the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oi!
[SPEAKER_01]: Get off the fucking stage!
[SPEAKER_01]: And he kind of, like, throws something towards the corner stage, where there's a bunch of revelers on there just, like, pissing about, and he kind of throws some people off, and he goes, uh, look, you can get up there whenever you want, mate.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know the drill, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: 50% to the house, you keep the rest, and yeah, you'll have a room here tonight if you want it as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've got some space.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah boss, don't you think tonight is a special night so I should receive a bit more?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean look at all these people.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look at everyone outside.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what my music can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can attract more than this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, make a persuasion jack.
[SPEAKER_01]: First roll!
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, first roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: Little 20!
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, it still does the double thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So annoying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pissed me away around that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, with a 10, he goes, alright, 60%.
[SPEAKER_01]: 40 to the house.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll take 60%, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can head over and start doing a show, if you so wish, in the corner of the plumber.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I will have a drink and then head towards the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you start setting up some music in the corner.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, I'm going to put on some much more... Much more lute-like music.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's, you know, there's a crowd, there's people enjoying themselves here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meanwhile, in this area, just outside the Plum and Bob, you hear some music starting up.
[SPEAKER_01]: And by you, I am talking about Calder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Calder, you are here for whatever reason.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can...
[SPEAKER_01]: tell us or not but you are here in the uh just walking around kind of enjoying the festivities on a night off um give us an idea of kind of what you look like who you are kind of what kind of behavior you might be having in this in this marketplace at the moment um so culture probably would be just wandering over there maybe looking a little bit tired after you know long heavy
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know, work week, so to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you cosplaying yourself?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Probably going to like, also, I don't know, just chilling, eating a little bit good food over there and then probably going to have a drink as well, just to try to relax and forget all the busyness.
[SPEAKER_03]: And how he looks is like, you know, average height and not fat, but not completely like lean, lean, more like normal body type.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then short dark hair and then kind of normal clothes, so to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, yeah, normal, normal people clothes, but long sleeves and then clothes on.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, oh yeah, and then small black horns also going on along the head.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can tell me whether you think you've been to the Plum and Bob before.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably not, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, you hear music.
[SPEAKER_03]: What is the age limit for the alcohol over here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like 12, probably.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think anyone cares.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not in this kind of place, at least.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think anyone's checking your age.
[SPEAKER_01]: They just kind of judge you and decide whether or not to serve you at that point.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you hear some music start up, some loop playing coming from the Plum and Bob, and head inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: um you uh enter into the bomb and yeah you see inside here um our vast uh array of different types of people i think make a little perception check i think when you walk in as soon as i find them first natural one first natural
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey!
[SPEAKER_02]: It's one of the best runs that I have heard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's not exaggerating.
[SPEAKER_01]: With the seven, you are a little shorter than the majority of the clients in here and you kind of just get that feeling when you open the door and you walk into a crowd and there's just people everywhere and you can hear the music coming from somewhere at the back of the establishment but you are kind of walking around.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not, yeah, I'm not saying you're particularly short but you are just
[SPEAKER_01]: the people in here happen to be polar, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, just, you know, just below average.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just below average.
[SPEAKER_03]: First I had to hear the average from Crimson and then...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I think the average height is whatever, like, I don't know what you Europeans call it, but like 5'11 is like average height roughly in... 175 or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, 175 ish.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's average.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm probably 174, so...
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe for the Netherlands.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I was gonna say, maybe for the Netherlands it's 180, but... 180 is below average, I think, for the Netherlands.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, the Netherlands is particularly tall, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But I think across western hemisphere generally it's like 5'11", 5'10", something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think it's like 180 for men and 170 for women is like the general height.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roughly.
[SPEAKER_03]: I would say I'm like 175.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not super short, but you just happened there's a couple of big guys as you walk in, some worker types that are immediately blocking the door and you just can't see around them.
[SPEAKER_01]: You kind of try and push your way through.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to head straight to the bar?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you wanting to do anything here in particular?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm probably looking a little bit around, like feeling a little bit out of the place, so to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: But then I would go for the bar disc and order
[SPEAKER_01]: your order of beer head over to the bar listening to some music as well from the corner as you do this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meanwhile outside as well we also find Billion who is also here for a reason that you can decide just enjoying the festivities or any particular reason as well but yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well yeah Billion is probably you would notice him sitting on like the side of the road
[SPEAKER_05]: A few crates are stacked up or barrels, and he's kind of crouched on top of it.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's enjoying a little snack, like a skewer or something.
[SPEAKER_05]: And you can tell he's kind of somewhat away from the crowd, but he's really seems to be into it.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's got a big smile on his face, enjoying the crowds and what he's seeing and basically taking it all in.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: And what does he look like?
[SPEAKER_05]: He looks like... What's the word again?
[SPEAKER_05]: Like a Darkin, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Darkin, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you can tell he's a Darkin.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's got a little bit of a purple skin.
[SPEAKER_05]: Quite decently long horns, curled up.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he's just rocking common clothing that you would see anywhere in the stacks or in the common areas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, true thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you are just enjoying the kind of the buzz of the crowd, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can also give me a perception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're a little bit elevated up above the crowd here as well from this position, so you get a little bit of an eye over everything that's happening here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you're chewing on a skewer, you're looking over the crowd, everything seems great.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no, you know, like you're just enjoying the ambience.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't notice anything of particular interest to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You probably still do hear the loop music starting up because I think probably up to this point there wasn't any musical festivities going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you hear a little bit of the loop playing coming from the Plum and Bob, but you're happy to sort of enjoying the atmosphere here as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lark, you are here because, specifically, you know that Theo is planning on doing a speech, a talk of some kind, a rally, like, it depends what you would call it, necessarily, and you heard him mention this at one of his meetings, and
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's not due to happen for sort of another hour or so, but you are expecting that to happen and you were here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the reason that you ended up here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But what you're doing right now, you can tell us and also tell us what you look like.
[SPEAKER_00]: And yeah, I think I am just like wandering amongst the.
[SPEAKER_00]: stalls and just looking at things but not buying anything so what you see is a young Ayla probably a bit hard to guess her age because she's like she's small she's like 150 155 centimeters very lean and
[SPEAKER_00]: She has a bit like androgynous appearance which also makes it a bit difficult to even guess her gender at first glance and she has very like round face, big eyes, button nose, bunch of freckles and fluffy hair that reaches
[SPEAKER_00]: just below her ears and there's like this light blonde highlight on the front of her bangs and otherwise her hair is like dark brown.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's wearing practical clothes that are earth tone and they're also worn but they're not broken.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're covering pretty much all parts of her body with like baggy trousers and a big light scarf.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she has tight bandage wraps around her arms.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's also like a bandage on her cheek that's probably covering a current scratch or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, she...
[SPEAKER_00]: If you study her stance at all, she is like...
[SPEAKER_00]: moving carefully and attentively amongst the crowd and paying attention to every people that she's walking towards that she doesn't bump into anyone and just being careful and a little maybe hunched.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can also make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Someone's gonna roll above a 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hope.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just about.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you look around.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear some music.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear the lute music start up at the same time.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you also spot the stage set up at the in the
[SPEAKER_01]: square itself at one end kind of with the stacks in the background for whoever's speaking would be speaking out over the crowd in front of you in front of them like towards the stalls towards the crowd etc here and you imagine that that is probably where you expect Theo to be doing his talk
[SPEAKER_00]: I think if I know that I'm expecting them to start the speech later I think I am drawn to the music and I'm gonna go towards the music to listen closer.
[SPEAKER_01]: sure yeah you can hear it coming out of the doorway as various patrons come in and out um do you want to head inside or you are just listening from outside yeah sure you can enter in as well uh make another perception check when you when you enter as well
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you are able to catch through sort of the gaps in the crowd you see this Ayla who is with a loot on the corner playing I don't think that
[SPEAKER_01]: [Aeska] mentioned that Asuka is an Ailer but it's probably not the most obvious thing but I think you can see that he's young enough that and he's not a Darkin and that's kind of the key basically like if they're under 28 and they're not a Darkin they have to be an Ailer as far as you guys are aware and so he has a bit of a radiance that you notice and he's the one who's playing the loot and yeah and otherwise you see various
[SPEAKER_01]: patrons in the crowd etc are you drawn to anywhere in particular in here are you getting a drink are you heading to kind of get closer to listen you've been here many times before so you know the layout you also know the barman and you know some of the regulars here who would recognize you and stuff as well i think i would go for drink to the barman what was his name harl like h a r l
[SPEAKER_00]: Hello Hall, you seem very busy today.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I get just a quick drink of just water?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just water?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's harvest fest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I drink water in here?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to spend too much money, so I think water is just fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, all right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You missed it out.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of very quickly like he's in the middle of serving someone else, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: But because he knows you, he just kind of like quickly dips under the bar, pulls out a water for you as well and passes it over.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, he slides us across and he goes, yeah, no charge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm feeling generous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have a good night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good luck.
[SPEAKER_01]: you see him kind of like step around and you know you see him walking behind the bar he has a peg leg like from the from the knee below and make a little what would this be history yeah make a history municipality check check
[SPEAKER_01]: It was not a saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: A history saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a 9, you don't know much about his past.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have never really been able to strike up a big conversation with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does look like he did something before he was a bartender here, but you don't know what it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: One thing before we get to our final player.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can show the pictures of everyone in more detail if you guys want.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not sure if you actually wanted me to or not.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we have Asuka here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have Calder here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Handsome.
[SPEAKER_02]: Handsome with horns.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Handsome.
[SPEAKER_02]: I knew it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have Billiam.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh, so handsome.
[SPEAKER_01]: The most handsome.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yeah, so three of you currently in the Plum and Bob, obviously not knowing each other, and Billiam outside at the moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, you are escorting Theo here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He asked you to come with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are carrying some stuff for him as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can see that he's a little bit nervous.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I will just...
[SPEAKER_01]: How do I make him like this?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a different sheet, so I can't just put him on the board like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So anyway, you see Theo and you and him are kind of on your way to Oblong Square.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're maybe a block or two away from it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's kind of hurrying along because he thinks he might be a little bit late.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's like, Theo, Theo, you brought everything, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You got the script.
[SPEAKER_01]: You got you got like the notes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've been practicing, but like, I don't think I'm going to remember everything, you know?
[SPEAKER_04]: You'll be doing fine to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK. Good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm glad you're here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, this is a big thing for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK. And I don't know how it's going to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I appreciate you helping me out on this one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Make it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can make an insight check and then you can describe who you are as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's gonna be a few sessions before we see a natural 20 with a natural one Theo is
[SPEAKER_01]: Theo seems pretty calm on the surface.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's always very kind of like a little bit nervous energy, but always very kind of friendly and open to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the fact that he's kind of like complimenting you and saying, oh, I'm glad you're here and that sort of stuff is not kind of unusual or anything either.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's always very like kind of friendly and open and charismatic generally.
[SPEAKER_01]: So nothing strikes you as odd or anything here.
[SPEAKER_01]: What does Felix look like?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, he's darkened.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dark blue skin.
[SPEAKER_04]: long horns, beard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very handsome.
[SPEAKER_04]: And a bit of a nicer clothes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, then probably the people that you see around here looking a little fancier for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you're carrying like a
[SPEAKER_01]: briefcase I guess for one of a better word like a satchel or something like that for Felix for Felix for Theo and Theo also has like a bundle of notes and you know it's like way too much you know he doesn't have like the need for all of this paperwork but you guys are bundling through the city streets a couple of streets away to try and get towards the the stage finally you arrive and
[SPEAKER_01]: you arrive at the square, but within the plumb and bob, Hal kind of hits a tankard with a stick and it kind of like, donk, donk, donk, donk, donk, and kind of gestures for you to stop, ask her as well, your kind of performance that you're doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Before that actually, make a performance check for me though.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's the moment he needs to shine, the first impression.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, 14, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Decent enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, it's a little hard to get going.
[SPEAKER_01]: You haven't actually been going very long before suddenly you kind of get interrupted by Harle, so that's a little annoying.
[SPEAKER_01]: But with a 14, you do a pretty decent job of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there's a few sort of tips rolling in.
[SPEAKER_01]: And after you're cut and everything like that, you make one mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can please add that, because you've only been doing it for like an hour or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, that's one call.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, a mark is a silver.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, a silver, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's only been like an out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's the money?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's in the inventory.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is 60% of, you know, the takings, because Carl will take his cars well, so.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you make a mark.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's not too bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, a silver, remember, is not as bad as a silver in the old system.
[SPEAKER_01]: A silver is 25% of a docker, a gold piece.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's more like 25 silver, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: so it's pretty good yes yeah it's pretty good yeah yeah um so yeah you kind of start to scrape up your earnings and things as harl is hitting this tankard and obviously um you guys who are in here uh lark and colder um you kind of like go to attention a little bit as this is happening as well um as this little odd and harl sort of shouts out across the crowd he goes uh
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey everyone, a mate of mine, Theo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some of you know him, he's a regular in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's doing a talk outside and he told me I had to chuck all of yous out so that you'd listen to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're going to be closed until the speech is finished and you better go and listen because I'll be watching.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he sort of gestures to the door with his stick.
[SPEAKER_01]: everyone sort of grumbles a little bit and he's like, you can take your drinks outside, don't matter to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: And everyone sort of starts to file out of the pub as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess you guys have been in there for like, for like half an hour or something drinking and whatever else.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, you head out anyway to the to the
[SPEAKER_01]: stage anyone want to do anything as you sort of head out at all are you just happy to sort of follow the crowd here and make your way out into the square yeah i'm trying to be like in the middle of the crowd trying to avoid crowded areas
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so outside, you start to see that there's some hubba building as people come out of the plumb and barb, and you realise that this is happening at all the taverns on the square, so Theo's obviously got some pull with the taverns here as he's managed to get them to boost his numbers essentially for this, so you start to see all the crowd converges towards this stage at the back of the square as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: From your position, Belim, you can kind of see the stage pretty well.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's up to you if you want to move forward with the crowd or you want to stay where you are.
[SPEAKER_05]: If I can see and hear well, then I'd probably stick to where I am.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think you can from the top of these crates.
[SPEAKER_01]: How about you, Lark and Calder?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're kind of moving with the crowd.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've been kicked out, so you're going to have to leave.
[SPEAKER_01]: But do you want to get closer to the stage?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you content staying at the back of the crowd?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, where do you want to be?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I think Kaldor would take his drink with him, but then I would try to get closer.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think I would want to go and greet Theo.
[SPEAKER_03]: I didn't know that he's giving a speech, so I'm like, ah, that's cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Going to support him in a way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you hear his name and obviously Clark did.
[SPEAKER_01]: It must be the person that you know as Theo, if you assume.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you head out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you aim to get closer.
[SPEAKER_01]: What about you, Lark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Depends, like when I exit the bar I'm looking at the side of the crowd and trying to see if there are any higher crates that I could step on.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I don't then I would try to squish through the crowd to get to the front.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see one crate with a darkened kid crouch on top of it?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got a pretty good view if you want to go there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think I'm going to bother the kids, so I'm going to start squeezing myself through the crowd to get to the as front as I can.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So both of you two then can make charisma checks.
[SPEAKER_05]: Charisma?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this is pure moving through the crowd kind of, excuse me, kind of like force of will to push your way to the front of a crowded square.
[SPEAKER_05]: I tried to do it with dexterity.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, dexterity.
[SPEAKER_05]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_02]: oh my god oh my goodness is this cursed he's walking by excuse me and someone else you're excused yeah not skilled just just straight kuzma i think it's like he said excuse me and he just pokes someone with his horn or something you know it's like
[SPEAKER_01]: You come out of the Pullman Bob and start to push your way towards the front and five minutes later you realize you're further away from the stage than when you started.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you are just like very confused because you're sort of, excuse me, and you kind of get pushed back a little bit and you're just getting buffeted around in the crowd and you end up quite far away, you know, probably about 30, 40 feet away with the whole crowd in front of you at one end of the square.
[SPEAKER_01]: um lark you do a lot better and you're able to kind of slip down the side where there's a bit less people um and kind of move towards and you're closer to the front like maybe within 10 feet or so of the stage i don't think you would make it all the way to the front row so to speak but definitely a decent view from where you are biliam up on the crates has got a good view as well ask you're sort of the last one to leave because you're gonna sort of get kicked out here um but you also hear the name theo um when he explains this
[SPEAKER_02]: Asuka will slowly head towards outside and will stick to the back, but also more to the sides.
[SPEAKER_02]: So not like in the middle of everyone, but more at the back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, just like on the edge of the crowd at the back.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll say you're about 30-40 feet away at this point as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, so Felix, you're following Theo along and there's a kind of like, um, you're just kind of pushing your way through the sides of the crowd.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, and there's a bit of an area behind the stage where, um, just nobody has kind of gone because it would be a bit awkward if they were just stood right at the back of the stage like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so you and Theo kind of emerge into this area and Theo goes, uh, all right, Felix, like, uh, I don't think there's going to be any major trouble or anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: I haven't seen any light.
[SPEAKER_01]: enforcers or anyone around in the square it's harvest fest right everyone's gonna be chill right yeah i also think so so okay a good one this okay
[SPEAKER_01]: And you know Felix, obviously you know that you have helped Felix prepare with this, for this, for this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is going to be the first time that he's really sort of publicly explaining his ideas to a greater public crowd instead of a sort of more private setting where he might have talked in the past about his politics.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's taking this opportunity with the Harvest Fest, the revelry, and he's managed to get himself a stage secured here and he's going to be sort of
[SPEAKER_01]: telling his story so to speak to this crowd and so yeah he sort of asked you here not as a employee necessarily or anything like that but as a friend as a colleague to come and sort of give him some moral support here as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you stay down at the side of the stage behind the stage, and Theo walks up onto the stage and kind of like takes a position, looks around, and you can see that, all of you guys can see that a couple of other people in the crowd immediately are like, oh, Theo, hey, Theo, you know, like, there's definitely a bunch of people in this crowd that know him, and he's clearly a regular at some of the pubs here, and people in the crowd know him, and you even see, like, Harle is, like, leaning on his doorframe, kind of, like, nods over at Theo as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so then there's this sort of like hush that falls over the crowd as people sort of stop to listen and turn towards him and see what is about to happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: He sort of like closes throat a little bit and then he kind of waves his hand and suddenly his voice is former turged so that he is way way louder and everybody in the square can suddenly hear him talk here as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he kind of
[SPEAKER_01]: looks around at everyone, and there's like this silence that falls across the crowd.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says, uh, friends, it's great to see so many of you here, even if half of you only turned up for the half price drinks at the Plum and Bob.
[SPEAKER_01]: And everyone in the crowd is like, and then you hear Hallmott shouts over what?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no half price drinks.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're paying for that Theo.
[SPEAKER_01]: and the over just continues.
[SPEAKER_01]: Harvestfest is the last day of the autumn month.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're here to celebrate plenty, abundance, but who out of all of you can say that they actually have abundance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who here finds themselves overflowing with riches, able to pay what they owe, put something away for the future?
[SPEAKER_01]: These are harsh times, everyone, and we all know it, but us, the people here in the stacks, in the core, even down in the bellows, we don't get to have a say in
[SPEAKER_01]: how those times manifest and you hear a few kind of people from the crowd yeah yeah kind of like the like grumbly kind of sort of agreement and he says
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't deny that the guilds have done great things for the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: I myself am part of a guild and I understand the value that they bring.
[SPEAKER_01]: But when the fate of humanity rested on their shoulders, they stood up and took the brunt of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: They did great work, but that was over 30 years ago, and all the rest of us are left with is the same tough life here, the same scarcities, the same lack of opportunities that we've always had to deal with.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm bringing to you today a new way, a new idea, where all Parvozians get a say, a vote for the future of Parvo.
[SPEAKER_01]: This would be a vote for our leadership,
[SPEAKER_01]: vote for everything that we can expect to want from the and then suddenly you guys here
[SPEAKER_01]: A huge explosion hits Theo's chest and the crowd immediately panics.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everybody runs and you guys watch a hole just open in his chest as an explosion happens in the center of the stage and he falls backwards straight in front of you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix kind of like tumbles down the stairs a little bit at the back of the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do immediately Felix as you are sort of right there and immediately the first one to react?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to watch Theo trying to help him.
[SPEAKER_04]: See if he's still alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: You rush over to Theo and take a look at him before we sort of resolve that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Specifically, everybody else, what are you guys all doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Immediately the crowd panics from this flash of violence.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a classic sort of like gunshot type of thing goes off and everybody's just rushing in different directions.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is chaos in the square now.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we'll just go one by one and let me know what you are doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whoever wants to start has an idea for something.
[SPEAKER_01]: how far am i from him so you're about 10 feet from the stage he fell backwards and he's a little bit out of sight from you now because he was raised up so he's down behind the stage somewhere but you're only about 10 feet from that you immediately get buffeted by someone who is just like running and who kind of pushes into you but yeah
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm already contemplating my skills because I'll just be a new person.
[SPEAKER_01]: You others can do anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, unless somebody else wants to go, then I think I can go.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I think Calder would have first feeling a little bit tipsy from the beer, but, you know, I'm happily listening.
[SPEAKER_03]: And as soon as that happens, you know, it's just instant focus.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think I would also start to run towards Theo because, I mean,
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to go help my friend.
[SPEAKER_03]: And at the same time, I would start to look at the surroundings because I didn't notice where that could have been coming from.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if I see, I don't know, anyone standing suspiciously up on the roof or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can scan the rooftop, scan for potential situations.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, make a perception check here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, that's better than zero.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You were kind of trying to look around at the tops of the roofs.
[SPEAKER_01]: In Parvo, particularly, there are so many nooks and crannies and places that are higher where the buildings are that somebody could have been and hidden immediately.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you do get the feeling that you were probably on the right track.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see everybody scatters from the actual
[SPEAKER_01]: crowd itself enough that you're at least happy that it's not somebody in the crowd right in front of him who like shot him immediately there right so you think like okay it's not someone immediately here in the crowd but like i have no idea where they could be shooting from in on the rooftops or anywhere else near him can i also cast the spell just in case sure yeah i think i will i will activate the mage armor on myself
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool, yeah, so Mei-Jama pops up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nobody sees that, but you are a little bit more protected.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Lark, Asuka, William.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think immediate reaction is like, of course, huge shock, but then I would just instantly climb over to the stage and try to run to Theo, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you run forward and climb up the side.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can make an acrobatics or an athletics check just to...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not really possible to fail this.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just more about how quickly you're able to sort of bound over and get to the other side.
[SPEAKER_01]: And with the 13, yeah, you do decent work.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get to the sort of like pulling yourself up the balustrade on the front of the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Looking down, you see like Theo like splayed out.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's kind of tumbled down the stairs that went up to the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: He sort of tumbled out and you see this dark in leaning over the top of him kind of like trying to
[SPEAKER_01]: either help him or, you don't know, but you just see him there.
[SPEAKER_01]: William and, yeah, Asker.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll let William go first because, yeah, and Asker.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think William's reaction would probably be to try and climb up, maybe get to a rooftop.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Kind of take cover, but also look around what happened and if you can see something odd.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can jump over there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like the sides of buildings are not far from your position.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can make an athletics or an acrobatics check to try and climb up the side of one of these buildings to get to sort of a second floor balcony like area you can sort of hide out on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Within 11 takes you a bit of time to sort of work your way up a drain pipe at the side, but you kind of get yourself a little bit higher up than you were originally and you get to the top of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: um ask it like heals herself for some reason healing hands healing healing i think it heals guys wait you rolled two fours on 2d4 because there's no modifier to that you just rolled max yeah
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, Asuka's immediate reaction is he immediately tries to make a running start towards Theo.
[SPEAKER_02]: and trying to push through the people but then he stops as he sees first of all Felix over the body and second of all Lark jumping onto the stage and he would stop and then just go into like a side street and just try to keep an eye on the situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't see behind the stage where Felix and the body are.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you do see Lark climb up over this stage to get towards him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you see at least somebody is going towards to help as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And sure, you can dart into the side.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far away roughly do you want to be from this?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're currently sort of 30-40 feet right at the back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think I think it would be like I think I would have that so that I would have the 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you get about 15 feet away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll pause for a sec for him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where did you go?
[SPEAKER_01]: I had a doorbell, I think.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go for toilet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll go.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm having a new drink.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you think how far Calder would be?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because initially I would have gone like on the wrong way from the tail.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah well initially you were about 40 feet away like the max distance of the square so I don't think you said how far forward you went but the crowd is kind of moving and spread out so you if you wanted to go towards the stage you can or basically move your full movement of 30 feet and be within 10 feet of the stage if you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: okay yeah so you rushed forward at full speed while scanning the the rooftops and everything that's that's fine yeah i will make you make a perception check uh asker and cold cold it because you guys will end up relatively close to each other colder you can make a perception check as well
[SPEAKER_02]: Someday you'll throw higher than a 10.
[SPEAKER_01]: Someday somebody will.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we'll just wait for [Billy].
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so yeah, with a seven and a 12, I think you both clock that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I think, Calder, you move first.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get within 10 feet of the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't see Aska.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aska's moving later.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Aska, you see this Darkin, who is like one of the only people running towards the stage, as you see Lark also jump over the stage as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you kind of hold back.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you see two people are running towards the stage.
[SPEAKER_01]: One has already made it there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: so is that everyone's kind of acted everyone's in a position of having moved forward etc so felix um you what do you want to do i suppose is the question check if he's still alive sure you can make a messenger
[SPEAKER_01]: You look down, you're pretty sure that this is a fatal wound, at least as far as you can tell.
[SPEAKER_01]: There is a huge hole in his chest where he has been shot by something pretty powerful.
[SPEAKER_01]: So your first reaction at least is that Jesus, that looks like a mortal wound, like he is in a rough spot.
[SPEAKER_01]: You wanna do anything else here?
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got the most time to react since everyone else is still kind of making their way over, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think I'll just be more in shock at the moment, not doing anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you're trying to kind of work out if he's even still alive and what is happening, and Lark, you arrive next, having just bounded over the thing and you're now like...
[SPEAKER_01]: within five feet basically and you can rush over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I rush to Theo, don't really like take much look into Felix yet because he's just like leaning over him so he assume he's like just a friend or someone so I just like rush to Theo and since the site is probably pretty gory like it's an open boond at his chest
[SPEAKER_00]: Lark goes into a little bit of a shock seeing that, but she like sort of dissociates and just like leans over to him and presses her hand on his shoulder and casts healing hands, healing, healing, healing hands, healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it okay to use that result?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can use that eight that you already rolled.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just go like, Mr. Theodore, Mr. Theodore, and I'm just casting that without really questioning if he's alive or not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you start casting that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Meanwhile, I think you're rushing forward, William, sorry, not William, Calder, and you're within 10 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to continue up and over or around the stage, or what's your intention once you get close?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know, I just want to rush Nexo Teo as fast as possible.
[SPEAKER_03]: While also still trying to look like if I see anything but if not then I'm focusing at the moment for Teo more.
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah i think for now we'll use your previous perception check you looked around you didn't see anything particularly you uh arrive and kind of come around the corner of the stage and you also see felix and you see lark with her hands like on almost like a cpr type position like hands on the chest of of theo but you do see like a lot of blood uh everywhere like around the the body as well um
[SPEAKER_01]: So ask it you lose sight of everyone who was going towards Theo at this point and Billy from your position you can see down onto the stage and you can now see three people approaching him to have already made it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Third one almost approaching as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you two want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: Would I maybe recognize Felix as like somewhat of a friend of Theodore?
[SPEAKER_05]: Like would I expect him to be the one who's helping him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's find out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I don't think I'd recognize the other two, but maybe... No, you're definitely going to recognize the other two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Make a municipality check for me as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You...
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah you definitely don't recognize the other two in any way um and then i will just check the timeline for this um no you don't recognize you don't recognize um felix either okay so then in that case my
[SPEAKER_05]: my perception or well I would be more focused on looking towards Theo and trying to figure out if they're helping him or if I should get closer to do something.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Otherwise I would have been more focused on trying to find a corporate or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah no I think from here you can just see a crowd of people around Theo you can't tell
[SPEAKER_01]: what they're necessarily doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you see two people, you see a third rushing towards him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think there's any way for you to tell whether they're helping him or looting his body at this point.
[SPEAKER_05]: But in general, people are running away, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: The majority of people are running away from the fact that there was a gunshot and there's danger and violence.
[SPEAKER_01]: The majority of civilians are just leaving.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's almost already empty.
[SPEAKER_00]: The way I'm touching his chest, my hands are glowing just a little bit and looking like trying to pump something into him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but I think Billy is far enough away that you're just kind of looking down on the group of people around the body.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's probably not bad, but it's like you can't confirm for sure what's happening.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then maybe maybe I would just see if I can get a little bit closer while I'm still on those rooftops.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can walk along the roof that you're at and kind of get closer to the situation as well, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I also just want to add that as soon as Eska loses sight of the people rushing towards Theo, he would try to get vision as well, but still stay to the sides and not rushing through the middle like the rest are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you can definitely get along the side of the stage, basically, and kind of still staying a little bit out of the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: You look as well and also see the same sort of thing as Billy and where you see two people kind of over Theo's body, but you can't make out too much from where you are at this distance, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You pump in the healing, healing hands and nothing happens.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, this is a huge hole.
[SPEAKER_01]: You kind of put your hands over the chest cavity and it's not like the heels not taking.
[SPEAKER_00]: I sort of almost refuse to understand what I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she's like, just trying and in shock, hands shaking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just like, what?
[SPEAKER_00]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: You wanna do anything Felix, yeah?
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe like, Theo, stay with us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Stay alive.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then maybe... Just... Look at Lark, maybe, like, maybe you should get into a... Hospital or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: What kind of healing houses would there be in this, like, area?
[SPEAKER_01]: I think in this immediate area, maybe not that many kind of official healing places, but you know that there are like
[SPEAKER_01]: hospitals essentially like run by the guilds there's the whole guild the institutes of physicos who are basically like a whole healing guild that would be the best possible healing he could get is if you could get him there um but you personally like don't really know anything about that other than like kind of you know about the guild but you don't you know you've not dealt with that sort of thing before um so you guys are still just trying to revive the oh i think you arrive at this point uh calder as well
[SPEAKER_01]: and you see those two kind of over the body.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think I would rush over there as well and then kneel, exit there and see if I can anyhow help, but I see these two already doing things over there and then I'm a little bit, well, not a little bit, but shocked as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seeing, try to see if there is alive at all, you know, eyes open, moving, anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can make a medicine check as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a good problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: 100% like you look at this.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think make a... You can make engineering check for me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Engineering, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Within 11, clearly he's been hit with something big, bigger than...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's bigger than like a small arms fire type of thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like clearly a particularly powerful weapon is what I'm trying to say.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not just like the kind of standard thing you might see like a pistol or something or a crossbow or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's clearly a
[SPEAKER_01]: beyond that level of damage and that's probably why it's kind of insta-killed him as far as you can see as he is basically bleeding out a huge hole in his chest like i said so you know you see the damage is serious yeah um you don't think he's alive yeah but i think it's it's made by you know small i don't know hand cannon or something like that and not magic not like
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah it's like yeah so it does it is like a gunshot wound yeah it is like a gunshot wound but it is not like a gunshot i mean you probably haven't seen any gunshot wounds but it's not like the kind of thing you would see from a small like a pistol hitting something like you know or one of these essence powered crossbows that you might have kind of seen as well it's not like that it's definitely something more powerful than that yeah um ask a billion
[SPEAKER_02]: anything you guys want to do you are both kind of on either side of the square kind of like overlooking the situation at the moment um from height or from just nearby uh i guess eska is going to still be vigilant and he's going to scan for to see if anybody uh who uh he recognizes uh will approach and oh yeah that's also a question would eska recognize felix or would he not
[SPEAKER_01]: um let's check i don't think i don't think so either because and i guess everyone else but i don't think it really yeah i'll double check this but um yeah uh no no basically yeah i mean for the smallest amount of context i can give basically felix has joined
[SPEAKER_01]: started working for Theo after any of you guys were at the Guild of Engineers, if any of you were.
[SPEAKER_01]: So none of you actually recognize Felix from working there, like he's not been there long enough for any of you to have been there at the same time.
[SPEAKER_01]: In terms of recognizing anyone else, Asuka, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you have seen Lark in the Plum and Bob before.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you just recognize her face like you would recognize loads of people in this crowd as people who live in the area, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_01]: And same for you, Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you've probably seen Asuka performing, but you can't currently see Asuka because he's hiding in the corner.
[SPEAKER_01]: But like, you two kind of know, you would know each other just by sight, like, oh, that's somebody who's around here regularly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Asuka is still just going to hide because he doesn't know if anybody that he recognizes will show up soon.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the research is too great for that now.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's concerned about Theo, but he's not going to show himself.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Curious.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, Lark just disappeared from me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I'm here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, like in, in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, in role 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, Blim, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will say actually you've been on the roof long enough that I think you can make another attempt at a perception check, scanning still for threats from your like elevated position in case there's still something potentially dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: better, for sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: The immediate rooftops that you just climbed up to, and the ones on the opposite side of the square, you don't see anyone.
[SPEAKER_01]: That could obviously mean that they sort of fired and immediately left, but you don't see anyone now, you see no current danger or threat of any kind.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think what you hear, though,
[SPEAKER_01]: is you hear something that is a little bit more familiar to you which is a um bell that is like an alarm bell in like a general alarm for the city like oh shit like there's a like something's happened somebody who's who's fled from the scene here has obviously got to somewhere where there's like a bell or an alarm and has is ringing it to be like help help like shit's going down like they don't know what happens but yeah they don't know if it's a
[SPEAKER_05]: big problem or not, but they're calling for people to come.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so that's a good sign at least.
[SPEAKER_05]: Would you say that the street is kind of getting empty?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I feel like William would wait until there's more space.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the square at this point is completely empty, I would say.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, it's so empty that there's a different screen for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks slightly different now.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a slightly different angle, but it's completely empty.
[SPEAKER_01]: And yes, everybody has like fled in just that same way that like, sure, some of these people know Theo, but none of them were brave enough to step up and follow up on what happened as you guys have been.
[SPEAKER_01]: So now it's just really you guys and Theo left in the area, although sort of ask us hiding out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Harle from the Plum and Bob has
[SPEAKER_01]: like locked his door but he's kind of watching he's kind of like looking out from the window towards the stage as well and kind of keeping himself clear but he doesn't even come over either um again there's just like a fear of not knowing what this potentially could be yeah then i guess sorry would there be past like a minute now maybe like in a minute people would clear out from this small area yeah yeah it's been like maybe a minute like
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I would say Billy is then going to make his way down again, climbing down and like not hurrying towards Theo, but making his way there kind of slowly and.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, yeah, you sort of also.
[SPEAKER_05]: He expects it to be safe now, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah, you yeah, you end up kind of closer to the group and you can see that I think as you get closer now you can confirm that they are trying to help him not trying to steal shit from him or whatever you see lark kind of hands on his chest trying to still heal him and the people doing various medical procedures and whatever as you approach.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do anything particularly here?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I'm just, I guess, checking out the situation, seeing what's happening to PO and what people are doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think now that Calder and Felix are there, like Calder also appeared next to Theo, Lark sort of, she's trying to heal but nothing's happening so she's still in shock and she just goes like, he needs help, he needs help, like, hospital or something and she gets up, because she doesn't know where hospital is or she can't carry him or anything so now she just like gets up and looks at the direction where
[SPEAKER_01]: someone could something could have hit him like sort of looking at the route that could have been for the bullet or something okay yeah so you can make an investigation make an investigation check csi hey okay um so you know where the body is landed and you know where he was standing when he was shot um
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a big hit, so it's hard to tell anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know anything about weapons and stuff, you don't know what the wound would mean, but you can see that from the position that he's in,
[SPEAKER_01]: It couldn't have because the force of the bullet hit him and he went backwards.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you know enough to know that it's no no one was like in the stacks direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: It must have come from the other direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: It must have come from the direction away from the stacks because
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise you would have been shot in the back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Looking in that direction, you kind of scan that there's many different rooftops.
[SPEAKER_01]: It goes towards the core and then you know beyond that is the furlong and beyond that is the outlines and all the spires of the guild, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_01]: So as you look out from Oblong Square in that direction, make a perception check for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah with the 13 from this square you can see that there are a number of kind of rooftops and stuff that
[SPEAKER_01]: could be a position for someone to like shoot down on, you know, like if it was like a sniper, essentially, but thinking of that sort of situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can also see though that from this position, there's like one, two, three, four guild spires that also overlook this area.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can see the spires towering up above and hundreds of windows like
[SPEAKER_01]: skyscrapers basically that also could potentially have overlook of this area as well but only four spires of which you don't know well enough to like immediately clock which one is which necessarily but like
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, these lines of sight are so obvious and clean that they look very dangerous to you in this situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's almost like Oblong Square is this big opening, lining up this perfectly positioned person to be easily targeted from any of these high buildings.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even though I can't clock the hills, I put that vision in my mind right now, just to remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the four of you are now here with Theo's body and I think only so far Calder is convinced that he is definitely dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Lark you can make a medicine check as well after you start to sort of like pump him with heals or try to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, with a 12 you sort of realize why it's not working as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been like a minute plus at this point and nothing you're trying in terms of healing or anything like that is working.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this close up, you just start to sort of accept the fact that this wound is so devastating that it would be very hard for anyone to survive this for more than a couple of seconds, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, it's pretty rough.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's just in so shocked that she can't even get tears out because she can't really realize that something like this can happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: So she's just staring at the direction where the shot could have come from and saying like, can we, can we help him?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it's, it's too late.
[SPEAKER_03]: The world is too bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who would do this?
[SPEAKER_04]: No idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: He was such a good guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: He was a great boss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Boss?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, boss.
[SPEAKER_01]: um ask it you are the last one sort of watching over this is now the you know this deathly quiet across the thing you can still hear in the distance this ringing bell that signals that you know people are probably coming this way soon uh whether that's good or bad um but you're overlooking the situation now
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you get the gist from their body language of the four of them over there that Theo is probably not doing well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm pretty sure that he after because he does see like Lark putting her hands on him and he sees like a little glow.
[SPEAKER_02]: He knows enough that he knows that he's trying to heal him.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, I think he probably drew the conclusion now that it's
[SPEAKER_02]: pretty late.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so Eska will... Yeah, I think it's going to be time to call them over.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Eska will
[SPEAKER_02]: Quietly or as quietly, loudly as you can do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whisper to the four people.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oi, all of you, get over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look in the direction to see who's shouting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think the two of you that were in the... the two of you that were in the plumber mob earlier see the bard from the plumber mob.
[SPEAKER_01]: The loot player is shouting you over.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Felix and William don't... you don't recognize him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, William would probably be like, where the fuck is this guy?
[SPEAKER_05]: Who's that?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm walking towards Theodore and getting close.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're going to ignore him or at least not go over to Asuka at this point, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see Asuka's face, like recognizing Master Bard and sort of instant trust to why he would ask to get over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I just like, I will go there with like glancing at Theo's body, very confused, but I go to Asuka.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kolde, feelings?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I'm just asking who that is.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think Caldera would have a little bit similar reaction, like just some random dude saying that, hey, come here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And my friend is here, so I think I would be staying a little bit here as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aski, you can make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to force you to persuade the players here.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're still, you're still set to private, but he rolled a 24.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's pretty much twice what anyone else has managed to roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, no, you definitely don't have, you definitely don't have to go, but you have this, you do have the impression that he is urgently calling you over for a good reason.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, why else would he be doing it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like that, you know, you get it's not like he's just a random guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, hey, do you want to buy some shit or something from an alley?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, like he's witnessed he's witnessed the same thing as you guys, and he is urgently telling you to come to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you kind of think there's probably a good reason for that, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Doesn't mean you have to go, but it does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I think I would then, you know, especially as Lark is leaving, then maybe I'm also, like, just staying a little bit behind and then looking Felix, looking Teo, then looking back to Aescar, and then I probably would go, so, I don't know, five seconds behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you start to follow after Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, are you following?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm probably also following, because I also don't want to get shot.
[SPEAKER_05]: fair play and and biliam you're kind of arriving from the other side of the stage you see the group of people and then you see you hear this and you and you see them start to sort of leave towards us yeah well i guess when i would arrive i'd probably ask like is he okay and maybe they'd tell me like well he's gone um so i'd kind of be surprised that they're walking away um and like i guess while they're walking away i would say well
[SPEAKER_05]: We can't just leave him here.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I would go towards Theodore and probably like, I don't know, like hold him or like at least be close to him, like waiting for maybe guards or someone to arrive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you kind of stoop over the body, but the other three arrive at you, ask it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I guess what I would do is, as another attempt, because I see the other three coming to me, I shout whisper to Billy, like, do you want to be the person who sits there when the guards arrive with a dead body in your hands?
[SPEAKER_02]: Come over here if you don't want any trouble.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're going to throw you in prison for this.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't care if you're the shooter or not.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're just gonna see somebody with a dead body.
[SPEAKER_02]: So get over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I start to look at the ice like, wait, what is this guy speaking of?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, Billiom.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know if that makes sense for me.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think Billiom would be too good natured to...
[SPEAKER_05]: He would be maybe too naive to think that he would get in trouble.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, but I will suggest that you may have had dealings with gods in the past that may not have been positive.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't matter because I see him being hesitant and I cast Charm Person.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: So make a...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a Charisma Saving Throw, I think, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Charisma Saving Throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you know enough about magic to feel that something is attempting to have been cast on you, but you resist it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Would I expect that coming from Asuka?
[SPEAKER_05]: Or could it be that I think, oh shit, someone else is targeting me?
[SPEAKER_01]: hmm what does charm person have to it it is one human eye blah blah blah oh sorry it's a wisdom saving thing not a charisma saving thing oh sorry i don't know why i read charisma no i i think i said i said charisma i just assumed it was charisma because it seems like a charisma thing so you can try again sorry that's a big difference in score
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's why you have to run.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise, I'd just take the first role.
[SPEAKER_01]: But OK, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, it was a bit of a difference for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you still succeed, so that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So for casting, it's vocal and semantic.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think he has to say something, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is just saying the same thing to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: But this time when he says it to you, you feel the sort of pull of magic for a second before you resist it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, then I think there's no other way than that... ...William would be suddenly very... ...very suspicious of this guy.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I would probably try to pull Theodore's body... ...towards the other side of this platform.
[SPEAKER_05]: And try to pull him away and get off the platform.
[SPEAKER_05]: Away from him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Away from Asger and the other group, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think at that point I would probably turn back and go run.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are you doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why are we touching him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I'm trying to protect his body.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know what I'm doing, but I don't know what's going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know either, but maybe we should just wait.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, that's what I'm trying to do.
[SPEAKER_05]: But this guy over there, and I'm pointing at Asuka, I think he's trying to use magic on me.
[SPEAKER_01]: he's trying to probably get you away it's not safe here well i don't see anyone here i think the the one i think as you say that uh as you say that ominous line um you hear the stomping of some boots uh from the direction of the bell basically like you just hear the stomping of some people running now in your direction towards the square
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you're still over the body.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lark has joined you.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other three of you are on the opposite side, kind of like in this alleyway on the right side here, kind of hiding, peeking over.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Asuka is, you know, shouted over at you guys, but Lark has kind of darted back and forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: So two of you are in the middle and three of you are in the alleyway at the moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I guess like a last ditch effort from Asuka to get them to come, because like he honestly doesn't care if they get captured or not, but he just wanted to try one last time.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he will shout whispers to them too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you hear those guys come?
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not coming here to ask questions about.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're coming here to arrest you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So unless you want to get arrested and be in prison for the rest of your life, I suggest you come now.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I start to leave.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get that urgent feeling that, okay, I have to believe this guy, sort of authority feeling.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I just tell Billy, I'm like, please come, come with me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I make an insight check?
[SPEAKER_03]: Like how... On Aske?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, well, Asuka, you can make either a persuasion or deception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have to say which one it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: And can I make persuasion to Bilyam as well since I'm trying to get him to come?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's so fun to roll against you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just bear in mind with these PvP things, the characters are still yours.
[SPEAKER_01]: So just because there's a high persuasion or whatever, you don't have to be persuaded, but it just means how persuasive Lark is.
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't mean you have to be persuaded, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: but with uh yeah with a persuasion check so cody yeah you're trying to read asker but he does genuinely seem like he's trying to help like he seems genuine um and lark is attempting to persuade you biliam to join the rest of them as you hear these boots stomping through the streets he might be right he might be but
[SPEAKER_05]: I just...
[SPEAKER_05]: I can't just let his body lie here.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's just not... We can't do anything about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying to grab your wrist.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I'm just holding onto Theodore's body as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your hands are like bloody with, you know, as you're trying to sort of hold onto him because it's literally like blood everywhere here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a horrible wound.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you were holding onto him as, as Lark sort of pulls on your arm though.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we should go.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, then, you go.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to stay here.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is...
[SPEAKER_03]: I think Kaldor would then say as well, like, maybe, you know, being shocked on this and then being confused that Asuka is saying what he's saying and then, you know, saying that maybe he's actually saying the truth and then hearing that people coming in.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then I also start to say to what Lark and William that
[SPEAKER_03]: I agree with you that, you know, I also would want to be with Theo, but something here is feeling very weird.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, this was clearly professional assassination and I don't know if they're looking for...
[SPEAKER_03]: Suntibukki.
[SPEAKER_03]: What is Suntibukki in English?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sundebuk in Dutch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, that's a drink.
Nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, scapegoat.
[SPEAKER_03]: Scapegoat of here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like, I actually, yeah, maybe it's better to get out.
[SPEAKER_03]: We cannot help him anymore and we definitely cannot help him if they're making us, I don't know, guilty of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just trying to pull Billy from his wrist and looking at him with dough eyes.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, Crimson, is this one of those things where you would say, well, we need the party to group up?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I think so.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, if you want your player character to live, you might want to leave, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: All I would say to you is,
[SPEAKER_01]: In the context of this, I don't think that Billy has a great opinion of the guards anymore than it's not like a situation where the police are coming and you think I need to give my statement because the police are lawful, helpful, friendly people that you have some, you know, you know, from your backstory, you have some already had some
[SPEAKER_01]: interactions with guards and enforcers and the police here are not the police the police are people with their own agenda and blah blah blah so it's up to you whether you think that the pull of staying and helping Theo is stronger than your fear of the guards or whatever or you think you'll be able to explain it to them or whatever you want to do right that's fine but there is a little bit of a precedent for you that that things don't necessarily go well can i leave it up to maybe a roll from Lark like how strong she's pulling me
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I just feel like... William is really, like, true in his intention to stay there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: But if she can pull him away, that might, like, snap him out of... Yeah, I think that's fine if you want to leave it to her.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do I roll?
[SPEAKER_01]: I will say, just before you roll, I will also... As you go back to the body, Calder, you can make an investigation check here as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, which will resolve in a minute, but you kind of go over and you say that this is a professional assassination and you are kind of in the same vicinity of as everyone else kind of over the body, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, like you can pull at you can make an athletics check.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could also use any abilities you might have or something like that if you wish to go that far.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's up to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh,
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I think like I already rolled 15 persuasion.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm I think I'm getting a little bit teary-eyed because I'm starting to like maybe panic a little bit because I don't want to stay here either, but I don't want to leave him here.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm also torn because I don't want to leave Dio's body here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm pulling him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm going to do it like strong try to do it strongly.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I also just looking at you teary-eyed like, please, please, please come.
[SPEAKER_00]: Athletics are.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, athletics would be... Well, actually, it's an unarmed... No, we should do the grapple rules properly.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's an unarmed strike.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can make an unarmed strike.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was it?
[SPEAKER_01]: And if it hits instead of doing damage, it is a... Unarmed strike.
[SPEAKER_05]: A save by... You're kind of against my AC then?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: How do I roll that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Click the part where it's like on the damage or the plus to hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, Crimson.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just to break in, if I click whisper and I type in the chat, only you read it, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or the whole party gets it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, if you want to whisper to me, you can do slash GR space type.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then that just comes to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, there was an error with your formula.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what's your AC?
[SPEAKER_01]: Lower than 17.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Other slash, forward slash.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, can you guys read what I just typed?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you need forward slash.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's not GR because it doesn't work.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, GW.
[SPEAKER_01]: GR is a role for rolling, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: GR is GM role.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unrecognized command slash GW.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, same for me on train as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where is GW?
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, it's...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm kind of sure it was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it's slash W space GM.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, then space message.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's whisper the GM.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that was.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was it?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't get it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's slash whisper, so slash W, space GM, space the person.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just like an MMO where you're trying to whisper a certain person, or in League, you can do slash W space the person's name, in this case, the GM.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you could also directly message, you could message slash G, you could do slash W colder than the message, and then you could send a message just to colder, for example, but I wouldn't do too much of that, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: so where were we you uh yeah so unarmed strike hits so you make your uh saving throw which is a strength saving throw i thought it was just against my ac no whether it hits or not is whether she's able to even attempt to grapple you like you could dodge out of the way but now there is a strength saving throw
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is a failure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you are able to connect with your grapple and grab a hold.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're able to grab a hold of him easily.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you all kind of are at this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just pulling now William towards Asuka as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And at this point I think Lars is starting to cry a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: You pull him away towards the alleyway where Asuka is waiting, Felix is there as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Calder, you are now remaining with the body at the moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you following as well?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you went over to the body, so just checking that you're also going back, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys get over to the alleyway as you hear the boots kind of arriving.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm assuming that you guys are trying to hide here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know you're trying to leave, but before you can even leave like you are, you hear the boots.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can all, we can make a group stealth check.
[SPEAKER_01]: So everybody make a stealth check and we will take the median roll of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my goodness.
[SPEAKER_01]: 21, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine and...
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, who's missing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, there we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that helps.
[SPEAKER_01]: That really does help.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the medium is 12, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: taking a larks check for the middle.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys try and kind of slip in, but you're a weird kind of combination of five people, there's blood on your hands literally, and you are kind of like moving through the alleyway a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you hear and see, a couple of guild enforcers arrive on the scene.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that Felix Billiam... Felix Billiam Calder...
[SPEAKER_01]: and Asuka all recognize them as Guild of Engineers and Forces.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they clearly are in uniform of the Guild of Engineers, which is a black and gold uniform.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have the symbol of the Guild of Engineers on them.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a couple of guys who are very sort of patrolmen, guardsmen types of guys that turn up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I can even show you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, a couple of these kind of guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: and you see an officer with them as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's two of these guys and an officer who turn up on the square and immediately kind of look around.
[SPEAKER_01]: And with a 12, I am going to make this guy do a little perception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who are the last going to the...
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I think, Calder, you and Billy are last in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix and Asuka are already in the alleyway, so to speak, but you kind of all join together at the edge of the alleyway here.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is actually, can I say that our roles are very fitting with the position that we are in?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, me and Felix are like, long gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Longest I've ever been to a portal, and then we come back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, I just love this.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's so good.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's so lore accurate.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's lore accurate, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, like, who wants to act first?
[SPEAKER_01]: Again, we won't do initiative just yet, as nothing is particularly happening, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Who wants to act first?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, you all hear this guy shout, hey, stop.
[SPEAKER_00]: I, unfortunately, as soon as I hear hey, Lark just like stops to, like, like a wall, she stops, like, she just stops holding billions.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess, I guess, Escar, like, Escar can't, can't get caught by these guards.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he just moves and he sees Felix with his side.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what he does is like, he just quickly shouts, whispers back, like,
[SPEAKER_02]: If you guys get out of here, meet up the plumber Bob and just move.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can't get caught by these guys, so he's just gonna go.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, I will say make a municipal literally history check, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wish I named that something better.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I'm going to change it to city, to bracket city instead of municipality.
[SPEAKER_02]: What if we're not in a city?
[SPEAKER_02]: How are you going to... Oh, finally.
[SPEAKER_01]: A natural 20 for a 19.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, you work at the Guild of Engineers, and there is a good chance that you outrank these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, the way that the guild operations work is you don't have anything to do with the enforcer's arm, etc.
[SPEAKER_01]: but you're high enough up the guild that your position would effectively make you their boss, although it's like the boss of a different department telling them what to do, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they have nothing to do with the kind of stuff that you work in, but you do know that you kind of maybe have some sway over these kind of guys if that's an option that you want to go down.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, you see ask or immediately dart off ahead of you into the yeah, I shout like meet at the club and Bob and it just Yeah, I heard that and then just see him leave and then I'll just need to go back out and I'll tell you when to walk out I'll go back to the to the rest And I'll shout to the officer there.
[SPEAKER_01]: They are with me Nice, okay
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you can't make a persuasion check yet because you're just making a claim they don't know who you are necessarily, but they start to come across, they're not running necessarily, you see the two sort of like patrolmen fan out a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: One heads towards the back of the stage, one's heading towards the other side of the square, so they're just kind of like checking the perimeter, doing their due diligence, etc.
[SPEAKER_01]: But one of them sees Theo's body as he does that, and he's like, boss!
[SPEAKER_01]: boss here uh and the officer however sees you guys and he's more interested in you guys and he walks across the square so he's now like coming towards the square to you so you guys will meet in the middle of the square essentially like kind of right in front of the stage if you wish felix um but yeah you say he's with you say they're with me and he comes across the the thing as well uh caulder billiam lark you hear a slash see this you hear asker askers darting down the alleyway to get away what do you guys want to do
[SPEAKER_03]: Would I recognize any of those cards?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I mean, I have been in the regions.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think there's just too many enforcers generally that you don't happen to kind of recognize these guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: But then I look at Felix and I'm like, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so you see Felix acting like he's got some sway here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know whether he does or not, but you see him acting like he does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to kind of like stick with him or are you going off down the alleyway after Asuka who is basically legging it?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I think I would stick here because I also a little bit like, like, uh, William, you know, in the middle ground that, you know, we haven't done anything wrong and maybe we can actually be helpful over here, but at the same time, you know, the police officers are not the most reliable, but now that we apparently have, you know, some authority, maybe it's actually worthwhile.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's William doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: I just stopped and I was holding her hand.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, I don't think William's ever been in a more confusing situation because Asuka really tried to pull him in and now that he's there, Asuka just bolted.
[SPEAKER_05]: Suddenly there's this guy who I don't know who says, yeah, they're with me.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't even know his name, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: I might even think that, like, Felix, maybe he's one of the guards.
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, so many thoughts are going through William's head.
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, he is just kind of frozen, I guess.
[SPEAKER_05]: No idea what's going on and just hoping for the best outcome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're staying where you are as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then Locke.
[SPEAKER_00]: You just froze when someone showed up in the first place and then... Yeah, I froze, but I think I just turned... Felix sort of stepped out of the car...
[SPEAKER_00]: step out of the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would just like turn also towards the officer or the guards enforcers and just stand there also frozen and just small tears.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the three of you stand there and then Felix is kind of like ahead of you guys approaching the officer.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk up to him and the officer walks up to you and he says, and who are you then?
[SPEAKER_04]: I am or was the secretary of Theo.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you'd probably say your department, which I guess would be like, I don't know, some kind of essence maintenance department or whatever as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes, who's Theo?
[SPEAKER_04]: Theodore.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't know him from the guild of Indonesia.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_00]: What the fuck is going on?
[SPEAKER_00]: What the fuck is this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Could we hear this conversation as well?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, you guys are all standing there, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jesus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice work.
[SPEAKER_01]: With the 19, I think what you're getting, you're understanding that it's not that he doesn't necessarily know who Theo is, but the Guild of Engineers is big, and it's sort of like saying, like, I work at the Bank of America, and then they go, oh yeah, who'd you work for?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Witchmark.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you said you're a sort of piece and you get the feeling that he doesn't necessarily know Theo's... Theo's not high enough and not involved in this department that he would like on a regular basis interact with Theo either or with you so that's why you don't necessarily know each other.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just work for the same company and work in the same building probably but you don't see each other very often.
[SPEAKER_01]: Within 19 you sort of, he believes you when you say that you work for Theo and Theo is whatever position Theo has at the Guild, I've forgotten what the problem is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's the Chief Essence Transfer Supervisor in the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're the secretary to the Chief Essence Transfer Supervisor.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you kind of say all the correct things here when you're saying that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the guy looks at you and he goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: right uh and so who are they he kind of like hand over these three two of them covered in blood um looking like you know regular stax workers not you know okay how how tall are you guys i just want to know how it differences here 175 180 so yeah okay
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I mean, basically, Felix is the tallest as well and the most adult in this situation, not necessarily based on age, but is the kind of taking the lead here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you three are kind of alongside him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I mean, this guy just goes, OK, they're with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: So who are they?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, Theo had a speech here, but he got shot and they were helping me trying to heal him.
[SPEAKER_04]: But to no avail.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: um all four of you who are there so ask it i will just say before this um you run down the alleyway you obviously kind of like it's one of those you're like i mean you're at the pump and bob get out of here and you kind of look back and they're all just standing in front of the guard like
[SPEAKER_01]: looking around so you realize that they are all kind of like not following you as you get around the corner but you have made it far enough that you're in a position where if you want to go back sort of stealthily you can potentially keep an eye on things or you can leave completely and come back later or
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not a choice.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you can also get to the Plum and Bob from here because you've gone through an alley where you can go around the side and you can go in through the back entrance that you know of into the back of the Plum and Bob if you want as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll do that because I just can't get risk getting captured here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four people I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you knock on the door at the back, and Harle opens it up, kind of like peeking through the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes, ask her what the bloody hell is going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of like pulls you in from the alleyway at the back of the Plumber Bob, and you're in the back room of the Plumber Bob.
[SPEAKER_01]: From here, you can peek out the window and see into the square, all of this happening, if you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: But Harle says, what the hell is going on?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you saw what I saw, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You saw Theo just getting shot and from what I can make out, he's now, he's gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry to say, he's gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, I saw four people rushing to him and looking at his body and I'm guessing they have something to do with him, but I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never seen them before except maybe this one small child, I think it was.
[SPEAKER_02]: and yeah lock oh oh you know her okay good yeah okay good good good good uh well she was there too when she tried to heal him for what i can see but he's definitely gone so i tried my best to get them here but uh to no avail but there is a possibility that they might come knocking later so be on alert close everything if anyone asks i'm not here
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I go to peak.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, make your persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_01]: okay he goes right yeah yeah just don't be getting any of them guild lot in here right i stay neutral and that's how i like it okay uh i'm not answering the door to them i'm pretending we're not home uh and he kind of like starts to go and like close the blinds and stuff as well as this happening but you can sort of peek through the shutters on the front window and see this happening here as well um yeah as you say that like oh yeah they're with me they were helping theo get shot etc all four of you guys can make an insight check
[SPEAKER_01]: They were helping Theo get shot, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, we're missing... Yeah, we're missing [Felix].
[SPEAKER_02]: [Felix].
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus!
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm so scared of our combats, guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Saving the good rolls for combat.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, combat?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want combat, what the fuck?
[SPEAKER_01]: Lark, Lark Calder Felix, you guys are still just shocked by the situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix is too involved in talking to this guy to really get this.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a 13, Billy, you think that when Felix explains the situation to this guy, he does not seem shocked or surprised like he should.
[SPEAKER_05]: you mean that the enforcer is not surprised?
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah the officer that is here does not go like oh shit someone was shot like as far as you're concerned he just walked into this square knowing what's happened right it's kind of weird to you um because you would expect someone who walked in here his his his patrolman who found the body is still over with the with Theo's body and he kind of said to the officer like hey come over here there's a body and stuff but now you're suddenly realizing this officer just doesn't seem like he's particularly
[SPEAKER_01]: surprised to hear that news right um as he is saying this this kind of stuff to you um so you notice that but the other three of you don't notice that um and yeah we can take a break here before we continue any further on that note i think that makes sense yep
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I really feel like I will also make a bot that scrapes the chat and records of our rolls because they are so bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's insanely bad, holy shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: It would be nice to get some statistics like how bad we actually roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think for me it's okay so far.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you guys have been like, especially you and Biliam has rolled so badly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's crazy though.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got the first one and 20, so... Yeah, you got your 1 and your 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's going exactly like my background story.
[SPEAKER_04]: 21, 21.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nothing in between.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, let's see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me see what I've rolled so far.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've rolled...
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I've rolled pretty good in comparison.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you've rolled pretty good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, in comparison to everybody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which also kind of makes sense because you were the most sort of... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The least panicked and the most kind of like... Fair, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Grounded reaction, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, my lowest roll has been... Let me see.
[SPEAKER_02]: My lowest roll was a 12.
[SPEAKER_02]: Could definitely be my highest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just wait until combat and then I can completely feel everything so that you guys can help.
[SPEAKER_00]: Has anyone watched those very important people clips of like the comedy show?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I watched the show, not the clips necessarily, but the show, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you watched the one with Zack, where he's like the positivity with the huge neck?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, the muscle guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's like, he's saying the, come on, everybody do a little clap.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's like stuck in my head for three days.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just going, I was like, come on, everybody do a little clap.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's like, it doesn't have any rhythm or anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's so bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think all of Zack's characters on that program are really good.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he's done two or three at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, Brennan was in one.
[SPEAKER_00]: I haven't seen that, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's in two, maybe three.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's on one with his wife.
[SPEAKER_01]: Him and Izzy, his wife, do one together, and that's really good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that true about...?
[SPEAKER_03]: I've never even heard about...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's on Dropout, the same place Dimension 20 is, so that's why I watch it, because I have a subscription to Dropout for the Dimension 20 stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, they blindfold the person and then dress them up as a character with really over-the-top prosthetics and stuff, and the person doesn't know what character they're gonna be, and then they bring them out to do a talk show, fully improvised.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have to make up a character on the spot based on what they look like from there.
[SPEAKER_01]: um from this costume that they've put on them which is yeah that's really funny you can find the clips all over the place and some of the episodes are on youtube and stuff as well but but then it's just to try and get you to get drop out but now that's going to be in my head because you've mentioned it again uh yeah yeah yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: After these insight checks, Billy has this thought as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, as this is happening, the second of the two sort of guardsmen, the one found that Theo's body, the second one was kind of doing a little sweep of the square, sees that it's empty and heads back over to Theo's body as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's these two guardsmen on Theo's body and then this one officer who is still addressing the four of you here in the center as this is happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this guy, this guardsman officer says to you,
[SPEAKER_01]: right well let me guess they're not from the guild then again so sort of like dismissive hand gesture towards the three of you guys who are standing with phoenix dismissive as in we have to leave or no just like he's kind of like it's kind of like um
[SPEAKER_01]: He's disrespecting you three, as if like, there's no way you guys are part of the guild, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Look at you, that kind of, these guys are clearly not with the guild, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: He says to you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: He probably not, no, but why?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, look, you can go, you know, no problem, but these three, they gotta stay, witnesses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless any of yous can tell me why you're here or...
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of looks at Calder, Billy and Lark here as you guys are stood there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he said, yeah, he kind of like is not, he's not directing his speech to you really.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he's kind of saying, unless any of you could tell me why you're here, then he's taking you three in as witnesses.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, we were or I was here for for the festival.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm hearing this talk like everybody else.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't see everybody else here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they run away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why do you run?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, there is my friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: Make a situation checks, both of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not perception, Calder.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a perception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: He finally rolls her up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys just happen to be here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear a gunshot go off.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hang around.
[SPEAKER_01]: You head over to the body.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't think to sort of leave the area.
[SPEAKER_01]: You think to hamper with the potential crime scene.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that what I'm hearing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, who?
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, Calder is starting to be a little bit upset of this thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, what is your name?
[SPEAKER_03]: Who are you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Why it feels like we need to do our
[SPEAKER_03]: Why does it feel that we need to do our work, or your work, I mean?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, well, I'm Sergeant Tanner, Guild of Engineers, Guardsmen Brigade.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are locking down this square on account of there being a crime.
[SPEAKER_01]: and uh should be pretty obvious to you there's been a crime he looks at like your bloody hands um he's like we're taking over the situation here and uh you three have been found tampering with a potential crime scene that we need to investigate this man here he points towards where Theo is guild of engineers uh employee and so uh we're taking control of the crime scene what's uh what's it do you
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you going to cooperate or not?
[SPEAKER_01]: We're just going to take you back to the spire, ask you a few questions.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can't you ask the questions here?
[SPEAKER_00]: I sort of give a little nudge slap at the side of Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I like to hear, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you four are doing this, you see the two patrolmen are dragging Theo's body around the front of the stage unceremoniously, let's say.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not particularly taking good care as he kind of like bumps across the cobbles as he's being dragged.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh my god, are you kidding me?
[SPEAKER_01]: His body's being dragged.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they're just like disposing of some body kind of situation, not, you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I yell over there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Show a little bit of respect for him though, at least.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of them kind of looks over at you and then kind of looks at you and like who are you and then looks at the officer who is just kind of like, carry on guys, don't worry about them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look!
[SPEAKER_02]: He addresses Felix again.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to have any trouble with any guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guild members, you know, I'm just here to do my job.
[SPEAKER_01]: Best for you if you just get out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pretend, well, you know, pretend like you just ran away when it happened like everybody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: These three here clearly tampering with a crime scene.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll be taking them in.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to make sure that, you know, they've not caused any undue disrespect to the scene and they might even be involved as far as I know, you know.
[SPEAKER_04]: They haven't been tampering with anything, I've seen it.
[SPEAKER_04]: They were even in the front, mostly.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've seen them do nothing.
[SPEAKER_01]: He steps forward to you, so he's closer, and he says, look, I'm trying to give you a way out of this, alright?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you're a member of the guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: just between me and you, you can just head off.
[SPEAKER_01]: None of this has to be your problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can just let me deal with these lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Everybody wins.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get some resolution to the situation and you get to go home.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the people that actually want to help don't.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's not how we're going to work here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what are you going to do about it?
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you going to do about it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Shankya?
[SPEAKER_00]: How close are they to each other's face?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, like he proper stepped up into your face, trying to be intimidating to you, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's quite a tall guy, but he's got a rifle slung on his back.
[SPEAKER_02]: How far is the lemon bob from where they're standing right now?
[SPEAKER_01]: From where you're looking out of the window, it's probably 20, 30 feet maybe, we'll say 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because it's kind of diagonal to the middle.
[SPEAKER_00]: when he says like, what you can do about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think at that point Lark would maybe step just a little bit ahead and say like, it's okay sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: And now she's like referring to Felix, like gender touching him, like it's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can cooperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can be a witness.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was at the front.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can ask me any questions.
[SPEAKER_00]: There doesn't need to be any issues.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm not the one making issues.
[SPEAKER_01]: As far as I'm concerned, you three can come with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, you four can come with us if you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just, again, he's not addressing you like he's addressing Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he just says, yeah, you four can come with us.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then he kind of looks a little confused for a second, I think, as he kind of looks around.
[SPEAKER_01]: and give me one sec uh he suddenly grabs his head and goes oh fuck ah ah fuck um as he takes 3d6 psychic damage what the fuck what did you do what the fuck um
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so he wobbles over in pain, and I think we have to roll initiative at this point because he is being attacked.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's initiative time, yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can't choose our tokens, so we just roll the... Yeah, wait a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, no, there isn't gonna be a token for you to choose here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't have a battle map for this, so just roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: What the fuck is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: You have determined ties turned on, as does Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a tiebreaker, so it's your flat dexterity score, so you would determine a tie against somebody else, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I quickly have to cut shit out of the cat's ass just a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: Magic.
[SPEAKER_03]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_03]: Any cloud mark the top?
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cut shit out of the cat's ass.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is like the most random announcement I've ever heard in my life.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're like throwing initiative and shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, guys, I just gotta cut shit out of a cat's ass.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it gives me time to put the energy in.
[SPEAKER_02]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, man.
[SPEAKER_05]: Damn, I'm quick on my feet.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ready to react.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ready to have no clue, but to be the first.
[SPEAKER_01]: What the fuck is going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, this guy's rolling initiative.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I do wish you could just add his turn, even though he doesn't have a token.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, god.
[SPEAKER_01]: GM.
[SPEAKER_05]: Econer.
[SPEAKER_01]: for the speed of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to raise full thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then these two are going to roll.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yet you're missing out, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just watching.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just watching this, you know, from my little my little window.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just like popcorn in the hand, you know, just like, oh damn, shit's going down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I could just roll things on with physical dice as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of quicker sometimes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on everybody, do a little clap.
[SPEAKER_01]: in a diagonal away from you towards sort of where they came into the square.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see that the two guardsmen kind of immediately perk up at this and look over to where he's like shouting and kind of looks, they look around like what the fuck is happening here as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: And so it's my turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this guy takes damage and starts to run away basically as this happens.
[SPEAKER_05]: like, recognizes, oh, he suddenly has a headache, or would I...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's much too extreme for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of grabs his head and then kind of runs.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I mean, the enemy of my enemy...
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, are we... We're outside now, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: We're on the street talking to this guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you're in the middle of the square.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean you're not talking to him anymore as you're annoying.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right, I'll just bolt to his side and try to hide somewhere, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, you can get back to the alleyway where you guys were when you got called out away from it if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, so he runs away.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then it is the turn of the actual officer who grabs his head, is in pain, runs away, turns back around, and he goes, which one do you...
[SPEAKER_01]: Which one of you did that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, he will pull his gun.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, he's got like a rifle on his back and he pulls his gun and aims it at the four of you who are stood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, three of you now, cause, cause, uh, Billy is running because Billy is running.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to shoot Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, just makes sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um,
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to use my reaction if he's hitting me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can decide if it hits him or not, then I can use it.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to make an attack with his Essence Carbine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He rolls a 16 to hit you, Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He will do five points of force damage unless you are doing something to react to this one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now let's roll first psionic energy die, which is in the six, isn't it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus in the modifier.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't take any damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know, sorry, six in total.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sorry, I forgot to roll some damage for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's an additional seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, five plus seven, as he does this.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll show you what it is, because I'm being fair.
[SPEAKER_01]: So his first attack does an extra 2d4 force damage on hit for overcharging.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's going to see whether or not that recharges.
[SPEAKER_01]: It does not.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he has multi-attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's shooting you again, Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you only take, so you take six points of damage, force damage, because six of it was blocked by Larg's protective shield.
[SPEAKER_01]: What does it look like, Larg?
[SPEAKER_00]: I reach like as he starts to shoot I reach my hand towards Billy and it just creates this I don't know how large the shield itself would usually be but um I guess the shield sort of just flies out uh white energy in front of the bullet that just like sort of sucks some of the damage in it yeah it can be like the kind of
[SPEAKER_01]: bit where the bullet is about to hit kind of glows white and yeah take and it takes some of the damage as well cool um but he will shoot twice he has multi-attack so he is a 14 to hit Billy the hits uh that is an additional six points of damage to you Billy
[SPEAKER_01]: So he turns, pulls his gun, sees Billy just running, and assumes, obviously, that Billy must be attacking him and running away, so he shoots twice at Billy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I also yell like, what are you doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Billy gets shot twice in the back, but some of it reduced by the damage from Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can see that the officer, though, is kind of like doubled over a little bit, still in pain from being hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the guardsmen who was over by Theo's body, about 30 feet away, rushes forward, can't get to Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I think in the line, the closest person he can hit is Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's going to run into Mellie with you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he just sees his boss shooting and
[SPEAKER_01]: he pulls his baton and will hit at you felix as well like these guys are not fucking around they're also outnumbered so they need to like do something about it right uh as far as they're concerned so he tries to hit you with his baton he rolls a nine though so he fails yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: this guy's got like a little a little sort of buckler shield that he pulls on his back and rushes forward so he's kind of like taking the front line tries to swing at you with the baton um misses uh doesn't hit you but it's your turn felix well as as he is in my face i will fight back um i will cast uh flame blade
[SPEAKER_04]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So a literal blade of fire just appears in Felix's hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: You slash upwards in like this cool motion, the flaming sword appearing and the guy just kind of like backs, like takes a small step backwards and it just misses completely.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you're still holding a flaming blade here as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, ask it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you roll initiative?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I did not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you should roll initiative as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you still should still be within the turn order to potentially do stuff if you want to do something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you can see all of this happening if nothing else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was whispered to me, but fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go after Calder, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you probably have a higher dex than Calder, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I should go before Calder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, Felix, you flame blade.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does the flame blade stay there for multiple rounds, or is it a one-off thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten minutes, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you summon a flaming blade in your hand, start fighting this guard with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not able to hit him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's the end of your turning, yes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, Asker, it is your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just going to stare out of the windows to see if anything happens, because I saw them fighting and I'm just like, holy shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: What the hell?
[SPEAKER_02]: What is going on here?
[SPEAKER_02]: And also because I don't want to expose myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Coldair, what are you doing?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think Caldre is shocked about what the fuck is going on over here, and then I cast Thaumaturge and make my voice... Is it double the normal?
[SPEAKER_03]: It was, you know...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a booming... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Something, something making my sound much... Three times as loud as normal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Three times.
[SPEAKER_03]: Even more.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm yelling to the gods that...
[SPEAKER_03]: You stupid, corrupted bastard.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was none of us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't you understand that somebody is trying to frame us and I also start to run towards, um, William who is looking hurt.
[SPEAKER_03]: So.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you shout this, you can make an intimidation check, I think is probably makes the most sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a straight one because they're not particularly scared of you at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, that's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: nice okay yeah the one fighting felix doesn't seem too affected by this uh the second guy who is thinking about kind of rushing in to join in the medley is kind of like taken aback a little bit as he hears that um and the um officer who is like who was just in some serious pain is kind of looking as well thinking like oh shit uh
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe these guys are a little bit more powerful than I thought they were.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so you think that he is also kind of maybe not rethinking completely the strategy, but he is a little unsure of himself after you do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You rush over towards Billy, you can get to Billy, you have the same sort of movement, so you can get over to Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do anything when you arrive?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, that...
[SPEAKER_01]: Casting Thelmaturgy is your action, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just looking at Billy, like, is Billy looking very pleady, very hurt, limping, et cetera, et cetera?
[SPEAKER_03]: How is Billy looking?
[SPEAKER_01]: How are you looking, Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: I would say that...
[SPEAKER_05]: I lost like half my life points.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's bad.
[SPEAKER_05]: So you're looking pretty injured.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you have two gunshot wounds in his back.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of which is not as bad, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah, you rush.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And maybe then if I say that Billy is so hurt, can I like... Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think in this case because Billy is looking so hurt that can I put myself just behind Billy that you know it would be more difficult for the guy to shoot Billy again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Behind Billy so he's in front of me.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not behind Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know Billy is in the front and then I'm behind Billy so.
[SPEAKER_01]: yes yeah in the direction of movement yeah sure yeah you can get between between them so that you could try and sure take a take a bullet next time yeah yeah cool so the second guard then who was alongside is going to make a wisdom saving throw
[SPEAKER_01]: uh with some saving fro
[SPEAKER_01]: true okay he is resolute enough to despite this still try and join him with his friend he's gonna rush forward and put himself into melee between the officer and everyone else which puts him basically in melee with you lark so one of them is on Felix one of them is on you the other two are running away so they can't catch up to those guys so he is going to try and hit you with his baton
[SPEAKER_01]: He has advantage because he is within five feet of his ally now, so he We'll try that again You guys suck yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah he swings uh he kind of like shield walls with his friend next to it and then they're both trying to take you guys down flaming blade in hand and then lark is there as he tries to like hit you but you manage to completely dodge out of the way of these strikes coming in um so yeah um perfect uh it is your turn so the positioning is that uh i am i am it's hard without the tokens i'm i'm there then there's this go guard too in front of me and behind him is the uh
[SPEAKER_00]: The gunner?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the gunner's like...
[SPEAKER_01]: He ran away from you guys, so he ran his...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think his full movement, so... Well, he wouldn't have gone 30 feet, so he's like 15 feet away behind the line of guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like a two-on-two in the middle, and then him... See the free action for me to pull out my quarter stuff?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got the quarter stuff on the back ready to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: and then i will attempt to hit him and topple him so do i cool but yeah so topple is just you just choose to do it if you if you hit him so now how do i i guess i press this just make an attack yeah 22 is gonna hit yep so you hit him you topple him but also roll damage
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, shut up, Pat!
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't hear my thoughts.
[SPEAKER_02]: You shouldn't have cut his shit off, you know?
[SPEAKER_01]: He wanted that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn!
[SPEAKER_01]: God damn!
[SPEAKER_01]: Your inner radiance damage shouldn't apply because you didn't... Yeah, I don't know why it's going there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have to...
[SPEAKER_01]: It must be toggled on on your sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to toggle it off on your sheet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: somewhere on the front page i think it is maybe in the combat and then you scroll down effects is it over there oh inner radians damage yeah so you want to toggle that off until until it's should be on but it's fine we can just take the two off this anyway but like when i toggle it off my cyan extract is here so it's weird why would it do that because that doesn't
[SPEAKER_01]: And the Psionic Strike is something that you choose to do to add to the attack, or how does that work?
[SPEAKER_01]: So once on each of your turns, immediately after you hit, you do the damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know why, like if I toggle it off, it just disappears from the sheet, unless I toggle it back on.
[SPEAKER_01]: uh anyway uh i do 14 points of damage yeah huge um yeah this guy takes a big hit uh oh um are you doing lethal non-lethal damage non-lethal damage in which case you immediately pull the quarter staff out and just crack him across the jaw and he goes down in one blow he does he does not have enough health i don't even sort of need to use topple because he just falls from the
[SPEAKER_01]: He is toppled, but not because of topples.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the thing with the topple is it costs no resources to use.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do it every single attack, so there's no reason basically not to topple him every time.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yes, you kind of do the like bash bash, sweep the legs, and he's already unconscious before you sweep his legs.
[SPEAKER_01]: His body just like sack of potatoes down on the ground as you knock him out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I jump over him and run towards the gunner with my full movement.
[SPEAKER_01]: You would still, you are still next to the other, the other guy was next to him, so you would be leaving the attack of opportunity range of the other guard if you do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I just take an opportunity?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can choose to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, he's going to try and make an opportunity attack against you as you leave his threatened area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, wait, wait, wait, stop.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll use luck, so I'll use disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll use one luck point, so you can just roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: I already said it because you started to roll, so I missed it.
[SPEAKER_01]: didn't help him even though it was disadvantage yeah he was fucked either way but yeah he misses anyway as you rush past and so you what's your movement speed just just 30 it's not yeah it's not increased by anything right speed 30 top left somewhere in the sheet yeah cool so yeah so you you can close i mean obviously he was only 15 feet of course you could close the distance you close the different distance on the gunner as well cool billy wait you have been shot
[SPEAKER_01]: in the back waiting yeah sure okay yeah uh so you've been shot in the back twice billy yeah you hear the sounds of fighting behind you but um and you also see that uh colder is kind of rushing up behind you kind of coming with you basically well i mean i'm just gonna
[SPEAKER_05]: Stick to my original plan and try to get away and find a place to hide from whatever is going on Sure, so you basically at the alleyway you can get into the alleyway and hide
[SPEAKER_01]: you don't know the area well enough to kind of know where this alleyway is going to go necessarily or where you can go from here but i just gotta get out of dodge sure you do know that aska said to go to the plum and bob when all of this was over if you know because you are bleeding and etc if you want to go in that direction yeah i'm not really thinking it's kind of like it would be yeah okay sure so you're just licking it cool but you use turn x strike in the damage you'll know
[SPEAKER_00]: I wasn't supposed to, but it was toggled on, so it used it automatically.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so you just have to use one Psionic Energy Dice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: As long as you tick that off, then it's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because if you didn't do that, he wouldn't be knocked out, so that would change a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you kind of have to do that now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Billy, yeah, you run.
[SPEAKER_05]: Make a stealth check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you kind of like dash behind some boxes and crates in the alleyway and kind of like you look down and you've kind of like got one, you know, like one slash across your ribs where a bullet is like grazed you and you kind of put your hand down to your chest to your stomach and bring it up and you realize like you're bleeding.
[SPEAKER_01]: It kind of mixes with the blood already on your hands from Theo, which has dried a bit, and now you have another coat of your own blood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, worst day of my life.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you get down into the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is the essence gunner's turn, the officer who is now in melee with Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is... Yeah, I'm going to say he can't use this rifle in melee.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has a...
[SPEAKER_01]: he has a melee weapon so he has to use that yeah like you're you're close enough to him that with this kind of weapon he can't use this in melee so he does still have multi-attack though so he's gonna hit you twice we'll try to okay oh wait he was on whisper uh he hits with a 17 i assume uh yes
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah so he's gonna hit you once with this damage of three force damage with his baton and he has multi-attack so he's doing it again the second attack when he rolls a six so he does not hit so he is like trying to fight you off with the baton here as well he doesn't succeed the other guard
[SPEAKER_01]: So this guy run up to Lark is knocked out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we'll take him out.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the guy with Felix who is kind of like looking a little bit worried now, like his mate just got taken out instantly and he's not feeling great about the situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he is going to make some saving for her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's fine with a 17.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is resolved to be a good guardsman and try and hit Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he does that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I tend to hit you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume he's not going to hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_01]: cool uh he doesn't have multi-attack so that's all he can do he just tries to tries to hit you and fails horribly and you can see that as he's trying to hit you like he seems to be affected by some kind of magic that is making his movements a little sluggish and it's a little difficult for him to move um as he tries to swing at you as well um but it is your turn uh we'll uh take him again with the flame blades cool
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm afraid a 13 does not hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: He deflects it with his shield.
[SPEAKER_04]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your flame bay just bounces off the shield as you are still like blocked in common with this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ask it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am chilling.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am chilling very hard.
[SPEAKER_01]: um well you say that but there is a loud uh song plays from the alleyway close to you uh billy as you hear an incredibly powerful sort of musical lute piece that plays um and yeah i think you're just gonna have to link it to me again asking because i will
[SPEAKER_01]: Asker is not in fact chilling, he's alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am definitely not chilling.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where is it again?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, this thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, hello.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got it, [Billy].
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you get it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Not yet.
Oh.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can you see it?
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's burning.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're choosing the enemies, obviously, only the enemies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you all hear this, and this beautiful song suddenly starts playing from the alleyways behind where Billy is.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Billy, you hear this, obviously, the loudest, because you're the closest.
[SPEAKER_01]: But all of you can hear this incredible music playing out.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you see that the remaining two enemies here will make charisma saves.
[SPEAKER_01]: or that guy failed.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is your DC?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where can I see that?
[SPEAKER_01]: It should be at the top of your spells list.
[SPEAKER_02]: It says DC 12, but then next to it, it says CHA for Charisma and then plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, eight plus five, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that would be 13.
[SPEAKER_01]: So saving throws are normally eight plus your proficiency plus your spellcasting modifier.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys proficiency is two, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Christmas plus five Your Christmas plus five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah more it says it says on the top it says DC No, I think it yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think your Christmas plus Through your Christmas plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah Christmas plus two proficiencies plus two so then
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, it's DC12.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's A plus your proficiency, which is two, plus your charisma, which is two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, it's weird that it says...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know what that plus five means.
[SPEAKER_01]: The DC 12 is correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's your spell attack bonus.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's to hit spells that you have to attack someone with is five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So your DC is 12, in which case one of them succeeds, the other guy fails.
[SPEAKER_01]: You watch Lark as the guy that you are fighting suddenly is kind of listening to this song, like he hears the song start up and he kind of like goes a little glassy eyed and kind of just sort of like,
[SPEAKER_01]: Lois is baton for a second and kind of looks like he is a little bit stunned or like confused standing in front of you As this as this melody hits the other guy is not affected by this That's the end of that call it I Think my my initial idea so maybe I just keep going with it, you know seeing that other people are not running away so I
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I mean, I got to help them because they are...
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know what's wrong with the cards.
[SPEAKER_03]: They are maybe so corrupted or something.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I was thinking to attack the big guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: So do I get advantage if I attack him with the spells?
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me check.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he is incapacitated, not stunned.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he is kind of like dazed and kind of woozy, but he's not fully stunned where you get advantage on him.
[SPEAKER_03]: How far would he be from me?
[SPEAKER_01]: You started running across, so he's about 40 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: 60-70.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because we went to opposite now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but the square is only 30 feet across.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he ran back to hit the lark, I think.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would I notice this, that he's a little bit weird?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think you see him like he's fighting Lark and then he kind of just drops his baton and kind of looks like he's like kind of listening to the music but like kind of swaying a little bit and looks a little glassy-eyed and yeah, it's quite obvious.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, whatever.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was my original idea so I'll keep doing that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So... Use Spellsword.
[SPEAKER_03]: That.
[SPEAKER_03]: 22 hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, 22 hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, Chromatic Orb, this is familiar terrain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and then... Fire damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do 14 points of fire damage to this guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is... Yeah, how do you want to finish him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this lethal?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I don't think you can non-lethally set someone on fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, who are you attacking?
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the officer.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what does the Chromatic Orb look like?
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's put it that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you cast it.
[SPEAKER_01]: What does Coldest Spellcasting look like?
[SPEAKER_01]: What does the Orb actually look like as you do it?
[SPEAKER_03]: So, I mean, if there would be somebody looking at me, you would probably start to see like some sort of, you know, almost like Caldor is writing symbols on the air and then casting it and also seeing the ice going a little bit more red-ish.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then you see just three, it's three, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it was three orbs coming over there.
[SPEAKER_03]: So then those would be just like,
[SPEAKER_01]: fire basically like a mini suns that are coming you know fireballs essentially just burning like a mini suns oh yeah i never read that part of the spell before but yeah it can leap to another target so you actually need to roll so if you roll the same on two d8s how do we tell that you rolled a three four and a seven so you didn't okay cool yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: But if you had of it, it would leap to a different target.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that new?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know, but that's super cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think that was a thing before.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's super cool, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: But yeah, that part doesn't happen, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Super, super cool builds around Chromatic Orb.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not going for that, but there are some super cool builds around it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Some builds in D&D.
[SPEAKER_03]: because I'm like, I'm like, wait, there has to be some very funny builds.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then I was Googling and then there are some
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean like optimized chromatic builds because then you get pinpointing basically you're basically playing like a ping-pong nice but yes it doesn't happen in this case but you hit all three orbs with one guy so yeah you guys watch three little orbs of fire kind of like manifest around
[SPEAKER_01]: Calder and then shoot across the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bang, bang, bang.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lark, you are watching as this guy is kind of like slightly dazed suddenly, distracted by the music, and then he just gets hit with three orbs of fire straight in the chest, throwing him backwards, and he is gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: They come over your shoulder immediately, and you're just like, holy fuck, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this guy is taken out in front of you, Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything else on your turn, Calder?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I start to go a little bit more towards William, maybe like half movement or something, so I'm not fully running, but you know, getting out from the alleyway as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or from the square, I mean.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, luck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, that wasn't meant to happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's your turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this guy just collapses dead on the ground in front of you, as far as you can tell dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: He gets thrown backwards away from you.
[SPEAKER_00]: It shocks me a little bit that he sort of looks like he dies in front of me, so I'm a little shocked at the moment, but also the situation is hectic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there still one guard at Felix?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, there's just one guy still fighting with Felix back and forward with the shield and baton, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: yeah okay i think i'm just rushing to help felix and i run at the back of this guard and i'm trying to hit him with my garter staff barter staff staff can i i can probably reach him because i think they were in the corner right yeah yeah it's yeah yeah you can does that hit um i don't think so because i think these guys are a little bit armored yes it does not hit unfortunately
[SPEAKER_01]: and you see this guy is not hurt at all yet he hasn't actually been hit by anything he's been tussling with with phoenix but
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you try and this guard seems surprisingly like he kind of gets hit once with the quarterstaff and looks over his shoulder like what the fuck guys stop He's like getting hit from both sides, but so but nobody's actually managed to add to damage him yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So He's kind of now stuck between you two But yeah, that's the end you're turning us like Billy Um, I would like to take the cry action
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, you were hunkered down in the barrels in the alleyway here.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm just kind of like scared and believable just like pull out like a small dagger and hold it with two hands just sitting there hoping that nothing comes at him.
[SPEAKER_01]: sure um yeah perfect yeah you're kind of peeking over the crates and you see like coldest flinging fireballs and like felix has a flaming sword and lark is like moving super fast with the quarter staff fighting these guys in the middle of the square and you're just like what the fuck is going on like um as you hide there yeah perfect um so this guy's dead so he doesn't get a turn um the last guy remaining then he's gonna make another wisdom saving throw and see if he is gonna
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he's even making it, he's going to make it with disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just like he is in a shitty situation here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a four, he is going to take the disengage action as his action, and then he's going to run 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he just starts rushing back the way that the guys came away from the square.
[SPEAKER_01]: He disengages so he doesn't take attack of opportunities.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's his whole turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is just running full speed away from you two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Felix, up to you what you want to do with that.
[SPEAKER_04]: um i'm going to throw an ice knife at him
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately you were the five.
[SPEAKER_01]: For the total of ten you do not hit him as you fling the ice knife towards him and he kind of like ducks behind a tarpaulin that's around the corner here at the same time and kind of dashes to the side and the ice knife like smashes off something over his head as he's like oh shit shit starts running away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything else you can do on your turn Felix?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're still 30 feet away from him after that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm probably not going to run after him.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm probably going to walk more towards Billy, William, and Calder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we sort of out of combat now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Essentially, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's Asuka's turn to do what you want to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Asuka, you don't have line of sight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I should, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because I went back inside.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I don't think you have enough movement to go out, cast a spell and then go back in and get line of sight again because the bar is probably more than 30 feet deep, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you wouldn't have line of sight right now unless, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, if you guys are happy to let this guy leave, he's 30 feet away right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you are all not going to chase him down or whatever, like Felix throws a nice knife at him, it smashes in the alleyway above his head, but he's going to keep running unless you do anything else.
[SPEAKER_01]: Otherwise you're out of combat yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So unless anybody tells me right now that you intend to chase this guy down, he's going to just get away and the rest of you are just in the square after this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: fight is over and you kind of look around there's a dead body now of uh well there's two there's a knocked out unconscious guy and there is a dead body as far as you can tell at least burning chest hit by fireballs guy officer of the guild of engineers is also in a bunch of crates down alongside you guys the three of you are standing in the square here um with uh
[SPEAKER_01]: William hiding nearby, and Asker is nowhere to be seen, but you did hear some music that I think you're all clever enough to associate with the fact that the lute playing Asker, you know, is probably related to him as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you don't know exactly where Asker is at this point either.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna walk to the, like put the quarter stuff at my back and I'm gonna walk to the body, that Calder birch.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna take the gun next from the body and I'm just gonna like angrily throw it to trash, like basically just throw the gun away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just yell, what's wrong with them?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I react and,
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe yell as well, like, hey, you girl, can you come here?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think this boy over here got hurt very badly.
[SPEAKER_03]: I saw you do some things with your hands.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe you can help him as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I start to go to watch William as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: William looks to call her and is like, wait, that's a girl.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now that you say, I don't know, I assumed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, I...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm just a bit confused.
[SPEAKER_00]: And... Yeah, I guess I walk to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: I will also walk with them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Better not stay on this place with a dead guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys start to walk away and the body in the center of the square begins to smoke a little bit as you look and see that his armor starts to heat up.
[SPEAKER_01]: The breastplate that he's wearing heats up and there's like a kind of coming off his body as he kind of like rides on the ground as he takes a bunch of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, the cardian that Lara...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the unconscious guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the guy that got knocked out, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I throw my hands on the... That's not on me, guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm also not doing anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think William is really paying attention much.
[SPEAKER_00]: The breastplate is like heating up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, when you look back towards it, it's like red hot at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I scan around us if we see anyone?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, make a perception check too.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would react to that and I would run instead of going to Billy now, I would take my guard yourself from my back and run to the unconscious guard and I would try to knock the breastplate off him.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I don't know if that works.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was just trying.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean, with an eight, you look around called a bit, you don't see anyone here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You rush over to the breastplate on this guy and you're kind of like poking with a stick, but you could tell, but like, I mean, you would have to burn yourself essentially to take it off him because the metal clips that are like fastened are also red hot.
[SPEAKER_01]: So with the stick alone, you're not gonna be able to like unclasp his breastplate as he kind of like convulses on the ground essentially.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think we have to leave this area before something happens to us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you guys see anyone anywhere?
[SPEAKER_03]: What is going on over here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, he says that I'll also look around then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, yeah, make a perception check as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I feel like Calder have enough knowledge about magic that you know something fishy is going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean, you guess it's magic, obviously, but you don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, make an archonography check for me, Golder.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you wish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds like pornography with magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's pornography magic and Golder's really good at it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, with a 23.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, with a 23, this is heat metal.
[SPEAKER_01]: You recognize the spell straight away.
[SPEAKER_01]: um this is heat metal cast on a big piece of metal the breastplate that this guy is wearing um and it's clearly a spell that's cast on him i think with the 23 you know that the spell requires line of sight like you know about this spell even if you can't do it yourself necessarily so you know whoever cast this however there are ways you also know of
[SPEAKER_01]: imbuing items with runes and triggering spells on a delay and stuff like that that could be a related cause to this but you you didn't see anyone around.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a 17 Felix I think the problem with this square is there is a lot of buildings with a lot of overlooking windows and
[SPEAKER_01]: anyone could be in any of these windows and would have line of sight to the centre of the square here, which if it's just a line of sight requirement for a spell, there's at least 20 windows that could see this guy, so that doesn't really give you a good indication of where it comes from or anything like that, just that there's a lot of places it could come from.
[SPEAKER_00]: When Felix says that I think we need to get out of here while the press play is burning this guy, I think I will just start running to the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Asger, I think you're kind of behind the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can open it for them if you want to as they arrive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy's still in the alleyway, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: You kind of forgot about him after the distraction in the center.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy, do you want to do anything?
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see them leaving the square at this point, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you peed up over the barrels.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Calder, you're still kind of away with Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm relatively close to Billy, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think Billy really wants to go home at this point.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know what...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, you are covered in the blood of a public murder, I will say.
[SPEAKER_05]: And own blood.
[SPEAKER_05]: And your own blood.
[SPEAKER_05]: You're also injured.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm more worried about my own blood at this point.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dream is like, oh my god, I'm gonna die.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think if possible, as I see if the two other are leaving to watch the bar over there, if I can go over Billiam and if I...
[SPEAKER_03]: So you look very young, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, and then I see that you're a little bit panicked.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's probably the same age as you.
[SPEAKER_01]: when you say very young he's not he's not that young like he's like your age yeah yeah yeah yeah but i think you can sort of yeah okay okay you can normally tell people roughly your age right like he doesn't look like he's like 12 or like you know like
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a teenager.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a teenager of around your age.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just don't want you thinking he's like an actual kid, just calling him a kid.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but seeing him panicking, I tried to act determined and then, you know,
[SPEAKER_03]: telling him that, okay, we need to go over there and I try to help him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if it's like, you know, holding him from the side, trying to walk together.
[SPEAKER_01]: You sort of like pick him up and help him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you are allowing yourself to be picked up, believe that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, in that case, I'll kind of like surrender to that and let him help me and I'll just go with it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: And are you heading back to the Plum and Bub as well?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's where all the rest of the people went and the only person that I saw... Yeah, I mean Asuka opens the door and yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, a bunch of you guys basically get...
[SPEAKER_01]: chaperoned or pulled in or you know head to the plumb and bob together and end up inside the tavern here where you also see Harle is looking very worried kind of behind the bar looking around kind of
[SPEAKER_01]: confused basically but asker is there having opened the door to let you in as well so the five of you are basically in with billy still kind of bleeding from his wounds nobody else took any damage right so i think it's just billy but oh you did yeah yeah you you probably have like a bruise or
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just a scratch from a baton or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah, so you're a little bit, a little bit worse for Wei, you two, as you kind of arrive together again in the, in the tavern.
[SPEAKER_00]: The two small characters got beat up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I think Cole is relatively small as well, in comparison.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did they, you said your height, so I was just assuming from that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm, true, true.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think he's taller than... 175 is not small.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's average.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no, that's true.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thanks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so what are you doing, the five of you here?
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess...
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess Asuka will scold him, like, well, I told you to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: and you didn't leave and see what happens.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, first things first, we need to help this guy though.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm pointing the gunwoods on this, this, Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or well, I don't know your name, but this, this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: We probably have to heal him up as I point to Billy.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then I suddenly cast healing wood.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: nice um yeah roll rolling well okay that's it's not that's not touch right yes it is just a word okay so you kind of like just gesture towards him and uh yeah you feel yourself get here for eight points of healing billy and some of the magic kind of goes around and what do you think your magic looks like felix
[SPEAKER_01]: What kind of colors, what kind of effects?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a bit of gray sparkles coming out, this one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gray sparkles?
[SPEAKER_04]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: So gray sparkles kind of start to knit up the wound in Billy's back, and you get a bit of healing back, Billy.
[SPEAKER_05]: So at that point, then I'm starting to feel a bit better, and I kind of get back to my senses a little bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: um and i would probably first say thank you to the blue guy and um and i was saying like i guess i just did this what who are you people and i'm like i'm thinking like this is like some group that i'm brand new to or something
[SPEAKER_03]: But before that, should we move further away from this whatever clusterfuck is happening over here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Like we are just basically next to it and I'm afraid that more people are coming over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eska then goes up to Hao and say to him, Hao, listen, I know you have a lot of questions right now, but
[SPEAKER_02]: If you keep this a secret and don't tell anybody and don't mention anything about us ever being here, I will pay for the rent for the next month.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, uh, oh, um, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, whatever you say, Asuka.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I ain't no friend of the guilds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I ain't gonna be saying anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, as far as I'm concerned, uh, misunderstanding and, uh, look, I'll say it was, uh,
[SPEAKER_01]: Blowboys what did this, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: For some reason in the square, there was a tussle with the guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: If anyone comes asking, I'll say it was a bunch of blowboys and they scampered off down into the tunnels afterwards, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sound good?
[SPEAKER_02]: Good, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I pick out the coins, I don't know how much it is, so I'll just...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just pay for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What did you offer him?
[SPEAKER_01]: The rent for the next month?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I guess like...
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess like, you know, it would be reasonable with what I have.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like I'm gonna say like, oh, you know, I'm gonna pay for a year worth of your thing or anything, but like... Just like, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think it's going to be 10 ducats.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, then I will deduct.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can de-duck it.
[SPEAKER_01]: 10 ducats.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you slide that across the bar to Harle, so chunk of change.
[SPEAKER_01]: that Asuka slides over to the barman as hush money essentially yeah yeah you open up there and they dragged it a little bit further towards the edge of the square but he's still there yeah
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, Lara just like looks out of the window and she just sort of shuts down there.
[SPEAKER_00]: She doesn't really, haven't said anything when coming in there and she just stares at the square quietly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so after after paying, you know, I guess I'm just gonna say like, because I think Asker would be the most curious one about what is happening here, considering his situation.
[SPEAKER_02]: So after paying the barman, he will just try to trust anybody who says anything and he goes sits down and he said, Okay, so who are you guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: And what is your relation with Teal?
[SPEAKER_03]: could be but do you think do you think we should stay on this this this close to this we could go like to the sewer system I'm I'm somewhat familiar with them so we could go a little bit vanish a little bit and then figure things out well do you have a place where we could stay because if you don't then this is the most possible place yeah
[SPEAKER_02]: In case we stay here.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can stay here, you can leave if you want, but in any case...
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't care, but I just need to know your relationship with Tio and why were you the one staying behind when everyone is running away.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, my name is Felix01AtnanNeldClaudius.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, this was the secretary of Dio.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I was next to him on the podium.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was helping him for the last year.
[SPEAKER_04]: Last year, that would explain.
[SPEAKER_02]: Next one, you?
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess like, Asuka would look to the one that's most able to talk next, which is Calder.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm, you know, also a little bit shocked, but yeah, I'm, I'm like, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm Calder.
[SPEAKER_03]: I, I just haven't known there for, for, I think it comes soon to like five years or something like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: He, or four or five, something like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: He, he was, he was good friend of mine.
[SPEAKER_03]: He enabled so many opportunities for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Were you also a member of the Guild of Engineering or are still a member of the Guild of Engineering?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think no.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are not.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you do know Tio?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, wait, before... Who are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll get to that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I gesture to Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: I say, girl, I think Lark was your name, as Hal told me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't stay to the windows.
[SPEAKER_02]: People might see you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I closed the curtain and I, with shoulders hunched now, I walk to the others and say,
[SPEAKER_00]: I...
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Distracted.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am distracted.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is there something in the air?
[SPEAKER_00]: Theo was just someone who I admired and who was...
[SPEAKER_00]: there for me at times when i needed someone um we we didn't know each other that well but it's he's just he was he was a good man and he didn't deserve any of this okay well you don't look the part but i'm gonna ask you also anyways were you or are you part of the guild of engineers i'm not
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, that's good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, you over there, the crying guy, stop crying.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not crying.
[SPEAKER_02]: Explain who are you and why are you at the scene of the crime when it happened?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't have to answer you.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I kind of walk up to, is Hal still here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's behind the bar, kind of, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Kind of show him, like, my hands, like, all bloodied and stuff, asking him for, like, maybe he has, like, a rag that I could use to clean up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah, he'll hand over some kind of, like, rag or something to you, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And at that point, I, uh... At that point, I will activate healing warts.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: you get another nine oh you're still on whisper oh sorry get nine points of healing um billy as well another nine look at me with the stats i'm like ready to defend myself you know
[SPEAKER_03]: But then I looked to ask, so can you now finally tell who you are, actually?
[SPEAKER_03]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_03]: You seem relaxed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Before that, I would tell how he doesn't need it, and then cast the Healing Word spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I gesture at William again to come back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Still covered in blood.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but I mean, I'm healing you?
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but I gesture at William again to come back.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm guessing you can understand what's going on here, so come back here, sit down, we'll have a talk, and then I will tend to your wounds.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, my wounds are fine now, I just want to clean up.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I don't have to answer to you, who do you think you are?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, you haven't even told us your name and you start investigating all of us while you're the most suspicious guy here.
[SPEAKER_05]: You better start talking or I'm out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, as far as I see it, I'm the only one who's trying to save your asses.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, as far as I see it, you ran away from us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, and I will explain myself if you come and sit.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm kind of getting close, but I'm not going to sit.
[SPEAKER_02]: My name is Eska Volan.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am the son of the prestigious Volan family.
[SPEAKER_02]: My father is the second in command to Dr. Tamerton.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I was trained to be Dr. Tamerton's next follower, as you would say.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am now disbanded by my family, which is why I am in this position right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: When the guards came, I know that they are not there for healthful reasons, seeing as they only came with a few when it should have been a whole army.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is why when I saw you guys over there, it seems that you have close connections to Theodore.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Theodore was a really good friend of mine when I was being trained at the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is also why I did not want to be seen, as you could understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, that's my story.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you know who would have wanted to do this to Theo?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it has been two years since I had any contact with Theo and any contact with the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_02]: While I was working there, I met a lot of people.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know a lot of people there, but a lot can change within two years seeing us also.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know Felix here, who is supposedly the secretary for Theodor.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, I plan to find out what happened because a good friend of mine has just been killed in the middle of the streets on one of the most important evenings of the year.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I was hoping I could get your help on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I will help you with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would they treat Theo like that and she points to the window and like... Why would they not treat him with respect?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would they just drag his body?
[SPEAKER_00]: Wouldn't the Guild of Engineers stand behind him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, like I said, like I mentioned, the fact that only a small number of guards were sent, and also the fact that the commander who was there didn't seem interested at all in Theo, from what I can see, it says a lot of things about how the situation is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe this was planned?
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe the guard was in on it?
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know?
[SPEAKER_02]: but I plan to find out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it definitely seemed like almost like a professional assault basically.
[SPEAKER_03]: It happened so cleanly and so fast and then afterwards like
[SPEAKER_03]: I first didn't know this or understand what happened to the gunner guy but then after all this hassle I realized or recognized that somebody is casting like heat metal on the final guy so it almost feels like they are trying to frame
[SPEAKER_03]: Maybe me for that kill as well, because I might have used too much fire power on the gunner guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not that there would be two burning guys, so it feels like there are also, or somebody is trying to frame me maybe on that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, as far as I can see, one guy did run away, so that could cause some complications.
[SPEAKER_02]: But for now, and I am guessing that he did recognize you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this might not be the safest place for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, I do need your help.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I guess the risk does outweigh the consequences right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: But and also we don't know if the guard, how much the guard remembered from you at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was dark and there are multiple of you and his two friends are, well, as I can see, dead on the streets now.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yeah, like I said, I don't know much about the situation, but I do want to find out if not only just in the memoriam of my good friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: While you're talking I see that Billy is like visibly uncomfortable just like being brought here and after all this hassle and he doesn't want to talk to Aeska either.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lara gets up and she just like slowly walks next to Billy and and asks quietly like I saw that you didn't want to leave Theo and I
[SPEAKER_00]: I was thinking the same but the situation just felt dangerous But I see that you also cared a lot about him Just like leaving it's sort of an open open-ended question Well, I mean I I Didn't know him that well Because he he's kind of like an acquaintance of my father and
[SPEAKER_05]: He helped me get a job, but I don't know him that well, or I didn't, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, seems like you knew the best of him, like I did.
[SPEAKER_05]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_05]: You can call me Billy, by the way.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm Lark.
[SPEAKER_05]: alone and then he kind of gets to himself like back to his uncomfortable state.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess I would say like well whatever the case we're here now you should be okay here for the evening so rest up and yeah well
[SPEAKER_02]: I am counting on your help for this case.
[SPEAKER_02]: And ask her to stand up and leave.
[SPEAKER_03]: Before you leave, I might say to you that I might have some connection.
[SPEAKER_03]: I might know some people that I could ask if they know anything what happened over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I would need a couple of days for that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, well, I too will also try my connections.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, I will of course do my best.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I hope you will too, Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: I will ask within the guild.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and I hope we can figure out something.
[SPEAKER_02]: All help will be helpful.
[SPEAKER_02]: and then ask our leads and go to this room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're going to leave the common room and head upstairs, leaving the four of you guys here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You all have work tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, maybe not you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, I mean, yes, you all four have work or at least responsibilities tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Asuka not so much, being a bard, making his own schedule.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the four of you, yeah, also, you know, you can stay here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have been offered rooms by Asuka and he is paid for.
[SPEAKER_01]: more than enough as a room for you guys to stay here if you wish.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is quite late on at night now probably midnight one o'clock by this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not unsafe to walk around the streets of Parvo at night any more than the day particularly so you guys can head back to your respective homes or you can stay here it's kind of your guys choice what you do next.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would
[SPEAKER_01]: on a metagame level suggest that you decide where to meet up again if you plan to meet up again and kind of make a plan moving forward before you all split up and leave.
[SPEAKER_01]: But other than that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, it sounded like everybody wanted to take a few days to get their contacts and then meet again.
[SPEAKER_05]: Which makes sense.
[SPEAKER_03]: So should we say now what day it is now?
[SPEAKER_03]: It is Kinsday.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, it is what?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's Kinsday.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think one hope for the wiki would be to quickly access to the calendar a day system because it takes a while for me to find it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you can write day to the search bar and then you'll find it in stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so the list of days should be in calendar and seasons.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can remember it like this, Kins Day is always the 001 because the festivals are always on the last day of the month and the 00 is the last day of the month and 00 is every 10 days is a Kins Day, so every 00 has to be a Kins Day based on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But basically, yeah, Ails Day, either sort of Monday, the first day of the week is tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: when despite the fact that today is a festival day and everyone's been out partying and drinking and stuff, that doesn't stop your responsibilities to head into work.
[SPEAKER_01]: For you, Calder, I mean, without any spoilers, you probably don't have a particularly rigorous start time.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other three of you do have like 9am starts or whatever, like you have a set rota, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess could we like agree that if we meet here on Wex day or?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three days from now.
[SPEAKER_00]: And at least Lark leaves like immediately to the night to return to her place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Billy as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Contra as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you three go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Felix, are you heading back to your home?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're the one who's... Yeah, we can go... We can go to Parvo.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can show you exactly where you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here you are in the Pollen Bob in Oblong Square.
[SPEAKER_01]: So nobody is too far from your home, particularly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like not too far to kind of get back now, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So all four of you head back to your various abodes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aska stays here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can all take a long rest if you wish for the evening.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then we will also stop the session there for tonight.
No!
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's play more!
[SPEAKER_01]: Why does it keep sending?
[SPEAKER_01]: Blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop blop
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so you guys head off to your respective places of work or sleep or whatever and set yourselves up for some potential
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll probably sort of time jump that for the next session so that you guys and you guys can sort of explain what you would have done in a couple of days before you guys come back together on Wex Day at the Pullman Bob to sort of talk about what might be happening next.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unemployed.
[SPEAKER_03]: And maybe, yeah, maybe we can also if we have some plans that we don't want other people to know necessarily, we can maybe send you a message, like, and then, you know, like, yeah, yeah, that works as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to look into certain things, I think the probably the difficult one is Felix as well, because I'm not difficult, but maybe let me know whether you
[SPEAKER_01]: want to go in as in as if nothing happened.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you assume that, obviously, if Theo has been killed, there's going to be a lot of turmoil in his office the following day, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't just turn up to work and do your job for the day.
[SPEAKER_01]: When your boss has been killed, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, there's kind of who knows what might happen there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But let me know kind of how you want to approach it in terms of, you know,
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know, just send me a message or something when you've thought about it about, yeah, how you're kind of approaching it, what you want to get out of it if you still want to kind of utilize your guild contacts and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: GG's everyone.
[SPEAKER_01]: The end of the session.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hell yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: We still don't know much about each other.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow, you guys know quite a bit about me now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm asking his full backstory.
[SPEAKER_02]: Otherwise, it doesn't really explain why I helped you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sorry, I was so focused on the name because I was...
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, that sounds so funny.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then I went to Wiki and looked at who that was.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you say the reason why you left?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I just said I was disowned.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's all I said.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's it, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we'll be on the next episode, I guess.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is a great marketing campaign, like immediate.